Right. I know I'm up early, but YouTube kicked me out of my own account again so I can't
type in the comments. So obviously the only logical thing is to start off streaming seven
minutes early as usual. Why is there no challenge thing that I break out?
Am I a broken app? I think I've broken chat on screen.
Ah, how? How? I've broken chat on screen. How have I done that? I can't get on.
See YouTube changing all its wee hings in there. Oh that's me. See YouTube. Oh that's
me complaining. Oh sorry. Oh sorry. That's me complaining. Good morning, good evening,
good afternoon. I'm starting five minutes early because YouTube's a stinky doodlehead
and signed me out of my account so I couldn't talk in the freaking pre-chat for a whole
five extra minutes so I was like, no, I'm booting up right now because I'm raging. I'm
absolutely raging. And I've freaking broken the chat. The chat doesn't display. So we're
going to have to do it manually, old school manually. Ready for this? Okay, hold on, hold
on. That's me. Nope, that's me. Why? Capture. Capture the pop out chat. Okay, stop it.
Look, it's you. We're having to do it. Fuck it, we'll do it live. I was literally having
to do it old school. That's so terrible. That's the best I got, okay? It's the best I got
with what I have. Is it working? Okay, I was like, we're on the telly basically. The only
way I can do it. I don't know if this game also is a game where we play it with the controller
or not. I don't know if this is a controller game or not. So I'm going to try a medicine
keyboard, but I think you can play controller. What would you kind of continue to do? Okay,
I will get marshmallows because I had a few questions. Snippets, listen up. Possibly
Yandere tomorrow. Yandere is more role play tomorrow. Possibly Snippets, okay? I am in
the process of getting a manager in that deals with everyone's Patreon audio. So everyone
should have two Patreon audios by the time I'm finished with today, except for me because
we sacrificed myself for the short term for the long term. The girls success is my number
one, okay? I literally said I can't even send a message in the long term. I've got another
eight hours sleep. So the mental clarity is returning. I'm not even kidding. The mental
clarity is returning. It's rather strange. I'm not used to it. Right, okay. I'll try and
avoid the incable questions because we are just playing video. We are just playing video.
We are just playing video. We are just playing video. We are just playing video. Are you squiddin'
me right now? Glesion, thank you for the extended membership. Hello, early story. Would you kindly
have fun today? I'm so making a would you kindly. Someone actually said I should play
Bioshock 1 and I'm like, you know what? I might. But the only thing I'm not looking forward to,
Sully Dean, as you interrupt me. Thank you Sully Dean for the extended membership.
Loves me Bioshock 2 gameplay. So I've not played it, right? I've not played it. I've played
Bioshock 1, right? But I might play it on this channel again, right? You need to forgive me. What's
going on? Thanks for all the fun streams. Big fan of the big thighs. Oh you let go. Awesome table to
catch it live but the VOD is delightful. The VOD got 18 plus. I don't know if it's still 18 plus.
I sent away for them to not make it 18 plus, but it might still be 18 plus. Thank you Tim
Shuttle for the tip. Yes, I'm a bit like, what's going on now? But anyway,
Hi, that one's a bit of a wet dream. So I can't read that one out.
Someone actually asked me. Hi, Strony. It's not very positive, but who goes there? Ken Quispy!
Would you kindly be your mummy until the end of our days? Bro, you're gonna be on your death bed,
you're gonna be like, mmm, mummy. Damn straight, you better be a bit of a main break to that point.
18 plus because I miss a cake. Would you kindly kiss me right now?
Someone said, hey, Strony, this isn't a very positive question. Do you have anyone in your
family that you only care about? That you care about only because they're family? For me, it would
be my ma hen because she's not that nice. And he kind of went on to be like, oh, he's nasty or that.
And I don't know if I said this story or not. I had a family member reach out to me.
You know, I didn't talk prior and I was like, oh, they're finally like taking an interest in me.
How nice, how kind. And basically, they messaged back and forth because he has a stepchild and he
was like, oh, the stepchild's interested in becoming a YouTuber. And I was like, oh, just make sure,
delete all social media under legal name, make sure you're not posting any memes that are inappropriate
that have racist stuff and all that type stuff. Because you know what is like, we're hooligans,
college 80 days, blah, blah, blah. And I was like, oh, that was such a nice conversation. That was
lovely getting into like the nitty gritty and all that. And then the family member turned around
and asked for 20,000 Great British Pounds from me. So that was really nice. Just had that lovely
conversation only to be asked for a lot of money. And I was like, ah, that's why you're talking to
me. And of course, when I said no, they no longer talk to me. Yeah. I literally, I literally, I was
just so disappointed, so so disappointed. Oh yeah, yeah, 20,000 Great British Pounds. And I was like,
ah, no, surprise, no, I'm not giving you that money. Because I know you're not one, I know you're
not going to give me it back to what the fuck. And three, they were like, oh, but make sure you don't
make sure you don't tell anyone else from the family because it's a bit embarrassing asking for money.
There's a difference between asking for 100 quid and knowing that I'll never get it paid back
type thing and just be like, oh, here's 100 quid. And then 20,000 Great British Pounds,
which is like what, I don't know, 30 grand United States dollar I do. I'd probably say that because
there's no actual real like relationship. And it just felt, it just felt really bad because I was so
excited to be like, oh my God, your child is interested in doing YouTube right here's all the
steps they need to do and make sure you have fun and you know, don't regret it because you'll regret
it if you never go for it. I was like so excited. And then it comes out of nowhere. Can I get 20
grand by the way? And I'm like, oh, you let me put my heart and soul into all these messages saying
how fun it can be. And that was it. Anyway, handle me sorry. No, you're not late. I'm early. I got
my YouTube account again. So I couldn't talk in chat. So I was like, boom, come up early.
And this is my whenever late reminder, I love what you do. And I want you to keep up the excellent
work. Oh, I'm glad you think it's excellent. I feel like I've been doing rubbish recently.
You've always you are you are and you've always been my favorite VTuber and ASMR. I said, love,
love, love you. I love you. Thank you for the kind word.
Hi. Good morning. Good evening. Good afternoon. Who recommended happy sugar life? That anime
seems kind of off brand. So I typed in one shot enemies like 12 episode enemies. That was the
most highly recommended 12 shot. So we're just gonna go for it. Look, if I like it, I like it. If
I don't, I don't, we can put it in the category and be like s to your category or a or all that jazz.
So we're going to give happy sugar life a shot. Then you worry too much. Then you worry too much.
You're doing great as always. Thank you. Possibly bad news cuddles.
In November, Apple will start demanding that users sign up via phone will be subjected to a fee.
Yes, do not sign up to anyone's Patreon via iPhone. You are throwing money
into the void that we will never see. So don't do it. Just as a reminder in general as well,
when you do give your girl $5 on Patreon, whether it's my gen mates, any of them, please remember
that they don't actually get the full $5 as well as taxes means they don't get the full $5. So
just keep that in mind when when I did that short and people were like, oh my god, you made $12,000
in a month. I was like, please remember, I don't actually get to keep all that. I don't just get
to walk away with that. There's quite a lot of investing and then taxes and then, you know,
it keeps going. So just remember, they don't get to keep all of it. Some people kind of forget that
little detail. Hi, strongy. Hi, reflin. Cowardly reflin here asking a question on behalf of the
snowberries. I was going to super about chicken. No, don't give me your freaking money for a question.
As you probably guess, it's about the data name change that I see indicated that should be asked
to you. I'm going to address it. I see can still say data. Okay, when you go on memberships,
harem emotes, harem membership, refling emotes, refling membership, bleeding hearts emotes,
bleeding hearts thingy. I see can still say data to her heart's content. I don't know where the fuck
any of this is coming from. She can still say data. I literally wrote data into her scripts. I don't
know what's going on with the whole data thing. If things are exploding over in the snowberry
side of things, I don't know. I think you guys are giving in to brain worms or some shit because
I don't know what to tell you. She wanted to change the name to Creamy Unpass and I said to her,
give me some time because YouTube had to approve the name change because, and we can still call you
pop, like YouTube had to approve the name change and I think if we changed it to Creamy Unpass,
it would get denied and then it would pause her Patreon, her Patreon. It would pause her
membership's temporary, temporarily, which is really dangerous. I need, I used to have her income or,
you know, like, I don't know what the, she can still say data. I don't know what the problem is.
Why does no one think that she can't say data? I literally wrote it into a script. Just look
on everyone's channel. Membership, it goes pinpal, emotes, pinpal, member tier. And now everyone
is uniform. That's it. That's literally it, okay? Like, AC was getting shagged for it so I said,
you know, you know, just tweet out and they can come to me but to be honest, I'm gonna be honest,
I thought you guys would figure it out yourselves. My hands are up right now in person. I thought
you'd be able to figure it out among, among yourselves. Hmm. There's some sort of correlation
between the bleeding hearts, tears and all these tears together, okay? Rather bra moment. I have
to admit, she can still say data as much as she wants. I don't fucking say, I don't dictate none of
that shit that happens on stream, okay? I don't, I don't dictate none of that shit, okay? Like,
the only thing I've dictated so far was as it is or maybe you slip on the league streams.
That's the only thing I've dictated. So, fucking, y'all need to, y'all need to pause
champ because, whoa, what the fuck? Okay, do we understand? Is that yes? Does everyone
comprehend what I've just communicated? And then that's it put to bed, okay? It's a bit of
brain worms. That's fine. Brain worms are natural, but just, just so we're all clear.
Hey, she can say data as much as she wants. I don't, I literally wrote it into a script for her,
okay? And, and the tier names are all the same for everyone now. It goes, oops, and membership.
Okay, okay, we're all in the same, what? Instrictions unclear. I'm pregnant! What? That's not how it works.
I'm sorry, I'm sorry for that time. What time? I don't mean to look like a jerk.
The only jerk you look like is you better jerk off now! I don't know what you mean. See, you've
got brain worms, clearly. What do you thought? You're not a jerk. You're a jerk. You're a jerk,
I know. You're a jerk. You're preaching to the choir. I'm not sure how many still
brain worms are here. Well, I don't know. But, but I don't dictate that shit. And I'm proud how
you're doing with the whole velar thing. Have, have you 20K, by the way? I did have 20K
reflinks, which is unbelievable. You're unbelievable. Okay, I hydrate with my teeth.
It's almost room temperature. Delicious. Yes, I'm very blessed to say I have almost 21K
There is a manager coming in for Patreon, which means I can focus on my reflinks stuff.
My responsibilities are getting less and I don't have to do anything other than my own content.
But yes, literally, I am getting so close. I'm on the cusp of greatness where I don't have to do a
single thing. Don't have to write script. I don't have to edit for the girls. I don't have to deal
with the Patreon uploads. And you know what that leaves me? All the time in the world to milk
my reflinks. I'm not even kidding. That's literally what we're doing. Like, I have finally, I've got
my mojo back. I'm posting some cheeky things on the alt-wear. Less stress and bound. Literally,
I've slept eight hours. That's two days in a row that I've had good sleep. And I think it's
because all my responsibilities are being lifted off of me. So, life is fucking magnificent,
reflint. I fucking love you. Everything's fucking amazing. Emma broke the game. She literally gets
more subscribers when she's out. Emma's fucking short, got a quarter of a million views, which is
fun. Fucking fantastic. She has three more on the way that are being brood, but the editor needs some
time. Cheeky editor. Cheeky editor that I want. He's in education. Get out of education right now,
just so you can become a shorts farm for Veal or I can't believe you're in education. Oh, shocking
behavior. Mummy has more time to gloop or giggle sticks. So, okay. Hi, Strawny. Fun fact incoming.
Did you know that I love you very much? I love you. Yeah, I'm on hyper today. Sorry if I'm too
hyper. Should we be making a tinfoil hat for the Bioshock stream? I don't know, should we?
What kind of plot is it? I've not played Bioshock. I've not played Bioshock.
Woooo.
Hi, Strawny. Just curious if you already know what stronzo means in Italian. A dinny. Hold on.
Time to open up Google Translate. Google Translate. I swear to god if it means like a goby or
something like that. Zettet ronzo. It's a... My name means asshole. What? It literally says Italian
detected stronzo, English asshole. No, my fucking nickname is ass. I mean, it's really on par for
me because I like being over. No, stronzo. Cazzo menta putana. Fucking means arsehole.
All right, enough stalling. Enough stalling. Oh god, can you hear the background music? Oh,
I was rather loud. Hold on. Let's pop that down a little bit. Pop that down a little bit.
Well, at least it's correct to all discover something new. Mummy is a big daddy. There's
a joke to be made in that. Right. I am so new to shores I've never played them in my life before.
Don't worry, I picked legendary mode. Press control to use a first aid kit.
Okay, I feel like this is definitely a... Oh shit, my fucking pin's not connected. Hold on,
I've pinned my fucking controller in. Sorry, I'm a controller clear. Oh my god, Lore.
Is this too loud? I'm playing on hard mode clearly.
Knock, knock, re-blend. I'm coming for your ink. Oh! Is that too low?
Hello. Let's go out to play, daddy. Bye.
We're in the rapture.
Oh.
Yeah, let's play.
Me with a cola.
Need Adam? I get to be the daddy?
Wait, they don't mind me? Oh right, I was going to say, did they not mind me being a big daddy?
Daddy!
Whoa!
I'm gonna bleed.
There we are. He's perfectly safe now. This is not your daughter. Do you understand?
What? Her name is Eleanor, and she is mine. Now, Neil, please.
Eh? Remove your helmet. She's under my protection.
Now, take out the pistol. No! Place it against your head.
No, no, no, no, no, that's my wing.
Fire.
That lamb is going down. What the fuck? That was my wing. I had to protect her.
I'm sorry, I want to turn down the game volume.
She went, mm-hmm. That was so loud.
Who goes there? Identify yourself.
Happy little game, bro. I'm already ready. Great. What the fuck? Eleanor, my wing.
Please, video game. Stop with the break.
Hmm? I'm alive? I made it? How?
No, what?
We need to protect Emma. Real and true. Okay.
I don't know what would be most easier.
I think mouse and keyboard seem easier today. I think we'll do a little chipping.
I can hear.
Does that need to turn up the game volume?
Huh, curious. Curious. Hold on. Oh wait, I forgot. I got a VQB asset.
Um, I got a VQB asset. Hold on. Wait, wait, wait. I got an asset. Hold on. I need to get it on screen.
I'm trying to be better at using fucking VQB assets, okay? I just accept.
The site can't be reached. Right, don't look. That's embarrassing. Don't look.
Stop. I'm messing it up. Stop. I'm messing up. Don't look. Don't look. Hold on. Hold on.
Cut the camera. I'm too dumb for this. Cut the camera.
Wait, no. Don't look. This is embarrassing. Stop. I'm a real VQBer, okay? I'm a real VQBer.
Right. Well, clearly the fucking line is going down. Right. Hold on. No. Wait, hold on. Wait,
how'd that rotate it? Stop. Oh, there we go. There we go. Eee-hee-hee. Right, and I'm a little bit bigger.
I don't know like that. Oh no, it's on my hair. No, not my hair. My arms.
Hold on. That's a little... I don't know. Is that Scott? I said,
is this more Scott than I thought? I think it is. Hold on. Right. Okay, this is totally going to work.
That'll have to do. It'll have to do.
Eee-hee-hee.
Sorry, Zura's helping me with her don't-a-thon. Right. Okay. Game.
Okay. That looks, that looks all right if I don't, if I don't go too high up with my elbow,
it looks fine. Okay. Eee-hee-hee. It's fine if I don't go too high up. Right. Okay.
Tell me if I need to up the game sound. I think I do by a couple of decibels. Right,
I've upped it a little bit. Um, okay. Zoom game, let's go. Right, what is this?
Fallen, fallen is Babylon. High the mic and lower the game a bit. Can you up your mic?
Are you trolling? Because I'm so loud normally. Okay, lots of people, very vintage, very coral,
reef. Oh wait, hold on. Do we have subtitles on? I need subtitles people. Audio options. Get those
subtitles on. Close enough. Graphic options. Get those subtitles on. Close enough. Customer,
no, not the controls. Gameplay. Dialogue subtitles are already on. No, that did not say I was playing
easy mode by the way. Get your facts right. I'm off to work. Have fun. See ya. That's what she
injects into the reef lens when they think they're dunning. Oh, oh, hello. Hi. Do you need a daddy?
No, okay. Oh, and me.
What does that do? Addonis luxury resort. Okay, I have a melee.
As fuel. Okay, we need to reserve our fuel.
Dude. Hold on. Hold on, scuff. I know. Wait, why no, not load. Options. Controls.
Why would CB crouch? Go and do the favor. Customize controls. And they're at most
use eight force control. No, customize the T. What? Oh, for fuck's sake, I'm actually gonna have to
do C to crouch. This is gonna go terrible. This is gonna go terrible.
Who the fuck are you? Because you weren't a big daddy. You're too acrobatic for that.
Addonis bats. Oh my god, it's already gonna, I'm getting freaked out. I'm sorry. I'm already getting
scared of this game. Okay. F to pick up. Why would it be F? Bro, I may have to do mouse and
peeve. I'm not even kidding. Hold on. I think I'm gonna be a cheeky sod and do mouse and peeve work.
Why is why jump? Oh my goodness. Right. Sorry, we're doing a, we're doing my game.
Bad thing. Warning. High voltage room generator. Well, that shit's barking.
Am I going against my first fight? I'm actually getting quite creeped out by this game
because why not you're done for. I just creeped in there. I don't like it. Press and hold.
Oh, why is it giving me prompts for the hook off?
Okay. Oh, for fuck's sake. It's giving me keyboard prompts. Why?
Stop giving me keyboard, friend. Gameplay. Customize. Use a flow system to control it.
Yeah. So then give me prompts for the controller.
What's this? It says I can scavenge something.
Beans. The first thing I get in this game is beans. First aid kit and some dollar
readers. Why not? Oh, that's right. The system in this game, you need money to buy ammunition.
Lam is watching. Well, I hate her already, so I can't wait to perish her by the end of this game.
I got drill fuel.
I got PTSD, the fuck?
Having me joined back. What are you? Take plasma. Okay, so big,
big daddy can have drill and abilities.
Okay.
Oh.
I think I've just got these most of the time.
Wait, why is my main to Nadadi that appears?
What? What is that? Why is it so fast? What's an eaves dispenser? Harder than Harvan.
I hate when there's two ways to go because I don't know which way is the safe way to look
and then like eat anyone. Enemy's in your...
Is that me doing those steps?
Am I so big? I'm like stomping.
Right. I need to go where she went. Sorry. Sorry. I need to go follow the...
I'll get it. I'll get it. I'll get it. Right. Okay. We need to zap the door awake.
Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Give me... Let me get up. Let me get up.
Lord of lords. I'm so written there.
Shocking enemy with lead trigger then quickly attack for critical damage.
Unfortunately, I don't have much mana. I don't want to be too wasteful right now.
I'm at a scavenger real quick.
Oh, I'm to shock that panel. Oh, you mean that super highlighted panel? Yeah, I need to shock it.
Okay. Health gain from bandages. Okay.
Now what? We going swimming?
The lamb is watching. Well, not for long when she's dead in a minute.
Oh my god, it's AC on the comms.
I mean, it is Tannenbaum. I know who you are.
Tannenbaum. Isn't that a song from Christmas?
Find me in the Atlantic Express train station.
Oh my god. We're doing it. And there's an arrow to tell me where to go because I'm too dumb.
Press back space to get... Oh, wait. Daddies don't fight each other.
Daddies fight... Daddies help the rapture be patched up.
Thank you. Good work, daddy.
Yes. Okay. Right. Daddies fix the rapture up. Okay. I got it. I got it.
Bonk. Bonk.
This is Dr. Sophia Lam with a message for the people. Remember, you are not alone.
I don't like you, Lam.
Think of me not as a leader, but as a mother to the rapture family.
The rapture family.
Hmm.
I don't like this. I don't like it. I don't believe her. Her lat. What?
Oh, it's a Gatlin.
What are you doing?
Heathen! Who are you calling a Dirty Heathen? I'm getting called a Heathen. I'm getting bullied.
Oh, shit. Is the chat broken? Sorry. I just realized this guy's broken because I'm not sure what to do.
All right. There we go. What is it? Kitty bar.
Hold X to reload your weapons. Stay away. Away from whom, eh?
What's this? A rivet gun?
Collected fresh water. Who is banging a boot? It's me that's banging them.
Okay. She calls herself mummy. She's an imposter. She has to perish. Literally. Freakin.
She thinks she's. Oh, hi, darling. Are you okay?
Or is that creepy acrobat going to yank you again?
Hi, darling.
Big sister.
Monkey.
Oh, I know my first battle.
I don't know what to do. I'm fucking suffering.
I, wait, hold on. I'm reloading. This isn't, I don't want to do my first boss battle already.
Are you a servant of the lamb together? You, you're going to perish. Sorry, but you're, it's over. Press right button for a fucking drill.
Okay. Drill time. Okay. That's doing nothing. And I'm almost dead. You're out of Eve. Find a hypno.
Why are you leaving? Why are you running? I wasn't finished with you yet. Is the boss battle still going on?
Use the first aid kit.
Okay. All right, fuck off.
Hmm. Yeah, simply in legendary mode. That's why I almost got rolled and smoked right in the first battle.
The first actual boss battle. And I like literally I'm only said.
Okay. I left on the D pad to heal up. That's fine.
No, go away. You suck. We will be reborn in the cold womb of the ocean.
When the, uh, this looks like a boss fight to me.
I'm scared. No, hold on. I'm scared.
Oh, well, good thing I can breathe under war. Right.
Warm womb of mummy. You should watch my ears.
Okay. Yeah, I was going to say, I'm pretty sure I can breathe under water. So I'm not sure
how this was like some sort of finishing move. Like
death of many great men. You will not last long. You can still reach the train station. Find me there.
Hmm.
Everyone's being mean to me. Yo, yo, how curious, curious, curious, curious. We must kill the fake
mother. Oh, I'll fucking take that. If that's that electricity. Thank you.
Swimming in the reef. Does the cold womb make a good cooler? I can refrigerate.
Yeah, put you in the refrigerator.
Wow. What an opening. Welcome to the rapture. Your beautiful city. Oh, it's me.
I guess we go down.
Well, I hope we go down anyway. So yeah, it's our job to like fix the pipes and stuff.
It's literally you through for us. See you big sister.
I said we're not getting a big sister for Jane too, because of you now.
You've ruined it. You've ruined it. Airlock.
Well, it's fine. It's so bubbly in here.
Oh, this is so different to the previous ambience.
Just a lot of cheeky.
Come upstairs to the ticket booth, and I will offer what I know of you.
Why aren't you playing on the Xbox? Oh, there's a sale on for all the bio shocks for $15. So I got
that one because you guys are saying that bio shock infinite is good as well. So I think we're
going to play that together, too. Atlantic Express Maintenance Facility.
Safety now. Please use your safety gear.
Now most to survive are like this. Spicers. Spicers are drug addicts, vicious animals.
Yes. Got a respawn. I need to save at the Vita chambers or pick up the hack to oh no,
no, no, no, no, no, no.
Oh, no. Is this a logic puzzle? To hack a machine, press a to stop the needle in a green section.
Is it easy?
Okay, it's fine. At least it's not logic based.
Okay, it's not logic based. I'll take it right right bumper.
Take out the gun. Right. Okay.
That's so bad. It's so bad. Bumblebee?
Bumblebee?
We got Bumblebee in this game? Hi, Bumblebee. We will be reborn. No yinx. I got Bumblebee on
my side. Sweet little Bumblebee. I know what you want from me. See, I'm not scared anymore,
you know? I'm not scared because I have health. The end of Ryan is the end of the cell.
I think I'm gonna have to melee the crap out of these.
Piece of lamb. I don't like you.
Uh, they have a flashlight.
Am I a tyrant? Be honest. Am I the tyrant? Where's my Bumblebee?
Dead man. Ten years subject, Delta. Since I watched you put a gun to your head and pull the trigger.
Wait, I came. I really is? I think I came back. Out of your pain, paradise was born.
I don't know how you survived. Neither do I. Your suffering is over now. These men will ease your
burden. Please understand. Oh, I'm a game just crashed. Sorry, my game just fucking crashed.
This is why I didn't play the new version because apparently this game crashes if you play the
remastered version a lot. Well, I hope I didn't lose too much progress. Hold on, let me make sure
it shows up on screen. Run there's an admin. I think I might have to.
I was like, oh, it started a little bit and then it just three of crashed. Okay, right, you can see it.
Okay, continue.
This is such a cute, I love the difference with the ambience of the loading screen.
Okay, okay. We didn't lose it for anything.
Imagine if I put you right back at the start. Average Bioshock screen. Oh.
Oh, oh no. Have I corrupted my file already? I'm going to open it and lower like all the
graphics and stuff. This wasn't part of the script. This wasn't part of the script.
Um, graphics quality low, I guess is what we're just going to do for now,
because I don't know why it's crashing.
Okay.
I don't, I doubt it's a graphic issue, but if putting it lower means it's going to not, oh my god,
the low graphics is terrible. I'm so sorry. I don't know why it's pressing, but
if it means we can play the game, right? Oh, wait, no, where's bumblebee?
Sugar. I've already forgotten. Is bumblebee ahead? I think bumblebee's ahead.
Okay, right. He closes the door. Yep. And then I grab this. Yep. Yep.
Monk. Monk. Monk. Sorry. The game's prompted me.
Oh, the game hates me. Be honest. Use. Oh, no, that's not right.
Brace yourself. Yeah. Use the controller please. Prompt me via the controller. That'd be great.
And then write bumper up for the drill. Oh, no, the Gatlin. Let's use the Gatlin.
Bumblebee. Okay, back again. Hit him with a back bend. Are you squidding me right now?
Just pretend your helmet is dirty and you can't clean it. What does that mean?
I got a bonus out of that. I don't really know why. Thank you, Lord of Storms, for the extended
medium not easy. I'm impressed. Wait, the game put itself on medium? I better not have.
Are you kidding me right now? Okay.
Time flies like an arrow and fruit flies like banana. Have a good day.
What? Thank you, Blessashimi. What? Time flies like an arrow and fruit flies like a banana?
Like a fruit fly on a banana? Because fruit flies are on fruit?
I don't get it. I'm too dumb. I'm too dumb. Okay, we don't have to do anything here. Just go straight
into this. Oh, wait, no, I did get attacked. Right, bravo. I got attacked. I don't know from where.
Where do you come from?
I feel like my my blunt attack should be enough to like absolutely annihilate them.
I'm just going to scavenge whatever.
God, the little graphics quality is pretty rough. I have to admit this is rough.
Oopsie.
Right, come on, Bumblebee. We've got people to kill.
Okay, right. Let's pray this doesn't break because if it breaks, I think we're in trouble.
Fruit flies like a banana.
You don't want to listen to that? Oh, they're not playing?
You. That symbol on your hand blocks you a dead man. Ten years subject, Delta.
Since I watched you put a gun to your head. I'm subject, Delta. But take heart out of your
pain. Paradise was born. I don't know how you survived, but your suffering is over now.
These men will ease your burden.
Please understand that like all I have done for you in D is an act of love.
It's a Sophia lamb. She has found you.
I can't do anything, Christopher.
Oh, I'm fire. I can't get out. Fuck. Jump bitch. Get out. What?
Out. Where am I going? Out. Help, help, help, help, help.
Search corpses for loot. I don't even see a corpse.
That's slam dunk, honestly.
This game looks like strong. No.
Now you know if the enemy we share, Sophia lamb, the camera in your helmet allows me to
watch through your eyes and help you to fight her.
Okay, hold on. Right. We're going to risk it. We're going to risk it. I'm going to put the
graphics back up because this is pretty painful. We're risking it.
We're risking it. Okay, that's much better. My PC might be screaming right now. Atlantic
Express administrative storage. Okay.
I'm applying with fire. Right. I don't need to activate the save station.
I don't see them. I'm just picking up my beans.
Where are the security cameras?
Oh, this?
Okay. Come on, Bumblebee. Show me what you got.
What's this? Bot shut down.
What? Like all bots? I don't know if it's worth hacking. Sorry. This must be...
I'm so sorry if you've freaking played this game before. I'm so bad. I don't know what to do.
Oh.
Oh, she's grown up because it's been 10 years.
There's a camera's catch on this thing, but...
I'm trying. Where are you running away from?
Telekinesis. Pick up big stuff with your mind. Throw out your enemies. What else do you need to know?
Oh, I remember these.
Throw objects at foes. You can even catch grenades and throw them back.
Evolved today. I remember the commit. Hold left trigger to grab objects and...
Okay. Something tells me I need to throw some stuff back.
Bunk. Okay. That was a good practice run. Let's go. Press X to reload the weapon.
I'm reloading. I'm reloading. She knows the way. She is the fake queen. She does not know doing.
Bumblebee, do you want to do the honors or do I have to actually fight?
Bumblebee, don't kid in the way, darling. I'll end up killing you because I'm a dumbass.
I'm getting obliterated. Sorry. How do I fucking take off telekinesis?
Get that shite off. Get electrical on right now.
I'm getting fucking... Wait, is this for easy mode?
Am I going mental or am I just really... And I'm out of fucking...
You guys didn't tell me this game was hard.
Right, I'm to loot bodies apparently. I don't know what for. Come here, what for?
I've just looted bodies.
Okay, I'm just looting. I'm looting everything.
Wait, I just did a 360. Get near me and you did a free shaky.
Sorry, but this game is not hard. No, I just suck.
Punishment for sucking. You need to send me an audio view.
Oh my god, the kitchen's on fire. See, this wouldn't have happened if that was the one that was cooking, okay?
So I'm guessing all the beans that I'm picking up will add to one health kit at some point or something,
or maybe it just heals me a wee bit. Right, hold to listen.
White is not black, Dr. Lam. Down is not up, and straw is not gold.
Look around you. Skeletons.
Rapture is no miracle. It is a product of reason.
Impossible in less one and one or two, and A equates to A's.
And yet, alone, each man is a prisoner to bias. Dream, delusion, or the pain of a phantom limb to one man.
They are as real as rain.
Reality is consensus, and the people are losing faith.
Take a walk, Andrew. It is raining in Rapture, and you have simply chosen not to notice.
Sophia Lam is using the splicers against you.
Most big daddies are like her slaves, guarding the little ones, but someone has awakened you.
What the fuck was that noise? Jesus.
All right, left bumper. Telekinesis.
Yeah, Ellie Bumblebee buzzing in my ear.
I know of your bond with Eleanor Delta. To save yourself, you will come for her.
But Eleanor has a...
Sorry, I just bought something by accident.
One you cannot share. There is no place...
An evil, a rivet. The rivets bolt together steel plates for the construction repair rapture.
I need to... I need to fix stuff to progress.
Butt shot down.
I don't know who or what I'm shutting down, but I shut down buttons.
You can hack the machine to lure its prey through.
That hummin', I thought that was my PC getting ready to take off.
What? I'm patching the hole. Fatchy, patchy hole.
In ethical psychiatry, we must account for the role of evolution.
Uh-huh. Depression fits a panic. Sexual pathos. All responses to ancient selection pressure.
Hold on a minute, this alarm goes. She's kind of preaching a little bit.
This theory is why Ryan's people invited me here. They mistake my stuff.
Peace off, ghosts. For the worship of competition.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Acrobat somewhere else.
One must know the beast before it can be raided.
Something's tingling.
Quickly, head for the elevator.
Uh, it's over. It was nice playing the game while it lasted.
Shut up!
Stop, you're panicking me!
That missed.
Shut up!
What is shooting me? Stop it! You're not Bumblebee.
Oh my god, I'm so bad at the combat. I'm pretending otherwise.
Can I just get one of you guys to play this game?
Okay.
She didn't notice? What was that to notice?
You will learn how to play hacking into the membrane now.
The combat in this game is always chaotic. You're doing great.
Eleanor.
Okay.
Oh. Oops.
He stole someone's?
Send me my gamer energy. I'm gonna need it. I'm absolutely just gosh awful right now.
But we start vomiting instead.
Hi. Would you like to fight? No? Are you sure?
Oh, the game is teaching us that there's no freaking
la bombas. Okay, so I don't need to do anything.
Bomb?
Well, that's a waste.
Uh, you got special ammo, press.
Fuck it! Up, down, left, right, B, B, elemental, P on the keyboard.
What?
Is there's no one?
Oh, I can just straight up pick them up off the ground.
Oh, okay. Well, don't mind about the Jesus. What the heck was that even about?
I'm scavenging. I'm scavenging. Oh, I need a whole day.
You little Alexander.
When the game gives you a first aid kit.
Or who wanders off unless a wolf is tearing at his flock.
When no aggressor is present, he regards his little sister as he might a common houseplant.
Do we need something more? Something stronger and unbreakable physiological bond.
Why aren't they one show?
Should be one show.
Oh, why is there so much food in the bin?
Uh, the chats are very cool.
Hello. Oh, hello, turning bomb.
Are you sitting here right now?
We function pretty much like the big daddies.
Without Strolly, we start to lose our minds.
Real and true. Thank you.
Oh, wait. I have a mark of a beast on the hand. It's a triangle. Relax.
Although that's in the babel, if you don't know.
They're like, oh, the mark of the beast is either on the forehead or the hand.
Hold back splasters. Oh, no, not a boss fight. Please. I suck so bad.
Use trap rivets. I don't know where.
I'm sorry. I didn't mean to do that.
He's off ghost.
I'm just putting traps everywhere. I don't have a fucking clue.
I'm trying. I don't know what to do. I'm just putting them down.
I don't know like the combat in this game. I suck. Please drop rivets. I'm begging.
I don't. I don't have any goal complete. Oh, thank God. Don't make me do that again. I'm scared.
Thank you. Now I must leave you. And I am sorry for this.
But there are others I must help before the city derounds.
This Manson Claire, he is an ally and will guide you to Illinois.
This game is aged. It's probably me. Let's be honest.
And good luck.
Oh, my name is Delta.
Look at you. A bona fide night in Alma, complete with iron horse.
Sinclair friendly. The name is Augustus Sinclair sport.
I guess the Sinclair style.
Old Tannenbaum and I share an interest in the old Fontaine building.
The very same place you'll find Elinor Lamb.
I think you and I can do business. Take the train to Ryan amusements. I'll see you shortly.
I'll see you shortly. From Augustus Sinclair.
But I do declare my name is Johnny Cutters is a fantastic opportunity to play your game.
I am honored to be able to explore this game for the first time.
I know the gameplay is absolutely terrible.
That's not going to stop me from enjoying it nonetheless.
I love the fucking the difference in ambience when you're in the menu loading.
Oh, we should watch Die Hard.
Well, I appear to have arrived at my destination.
As you can see, Chief, the station is iced over.
To reach Elinor Lamb at Fontaine headquarters, we'll have to clear the way.
Now, in order to melt that ice, you'll need a plasmid like a handful of hellfire.
We used to sell a fine old product called Incinerate in the amusement park up yonder.
Oh, you mean?
Find a way in. I've already been on all the rides.
Well, when you you tells me, sir, matter of fact, sir, when you tells me that I was only
got one way to go through the amusement park, who am I to say no to this fabulous opportunity?
I do appreciate it, sir. I really do.
We are but the stones to pave the way.
Now that's terrible.
The fucking rotation on a the controller is probably the worst part about playing controller.
Now, I say she is our salvation.
Now, that is a modified declaration.
I'm not sure you want to confirm nor deny.
Is that my footsteps?
I swear to God, if I'm fighting another daddy, I've had enough of fighting dad in one game.
I can tell you that much.
Is it just yourself, sir, in this fine bell dome arena area?
Is there something to scavenge?
Oh, this is a shoe shaining thing.
Like you go on the shoes.
Oh, I do declare this game is modified.
I must say the ambience, however, for someone of my skittish nature is rather
more defined, terrifying, even on legendary mode.
Alpha series, I believe.
Now, rapture's full of scientific wonderments just like you.
And if we can sell them to the world at my price,
we'll cure in your condition.
Now, hold on a minute.
I cannot do it.
Hold on.
Damage increase?
Very squinty arena.
Do the rest of the stream using my accent idea?
What are you talking about accent?
I spawned in like this.
I am from the south.
I have what the fuck I had.
I literally sound like this for real, for real.
Thank you, the booty lord for your kind generosity for your, your accompaniments
of your monetary pardon with your monetary values.
This is my real voice.
And I'm not doing a terrible job at this accent at all.
Truly.
I was hired to engineer a park the likes of which no man has seen.
Now all I do is watch over it like a grizzled sheep dog.
My first line of mechanical puppets made the children here cool with wonder.
But Ryan thought my vision was immature, antiquated, he said.
This place could have been something magical, but instead he turned it into a school.
No, a cathedral dedicated to himself.
Yeah, I can't believe he dedicated.
Yeah, I didn't care.
And now what?
Now I do not have no fights with no other daddies.
Okay.
I'll make that very clear.
I got a ticket.
I got a golden ticket.
Jam dandy.
That'll get you in the park.
But buying incinerates gonna cost Adam.
It's a sort of genetic goo that lets you rewrite.
Genetic.
I also have genetic goo in my marshmallow.
Well, yes, of course.
I know exactly where the El Dorado lounge is.
It's rather mighty.
Oh, I love searching me some file in cabinets for four dollars.
Yes, I'm in the security way.
Now there's no need to be so afraid.
What is this?
I appear to have myself something of a 50 caliber round.
Now don't mind if I do old sport.
Now this is getting exciting.
Now that wasn't very bona fide of me to do that against y'all.
But you have to forgive me for I'm rather entertained.
Oh my god.
I do apologize.
That wasn't very bona fide, but I still enjoyed it nonetheless.
That ain't gonna stop me.
OK, I'm gonna insert my ticket right here,
just like I insert my ticket into yours.
Oh, we got it.
You have picked up your...
You have picked up your mighty first gin tonic.
Tonics are passive abilities that have a variety of helpful effects.
Unlike Plasmid, you never had to activate tonics.
They take effect as soon as you quit them.
What the fuck?
In today's dangerous times,
it never hurts to be a little faster on your feet.
Remember, you don't have to outrun the crazed glasses,
just your neighbor.
I guess just shove it in there because I don't know what that means.
Now do get to admire the little...
Oh, go on then.
Cruising the Atlantic in his steamboat.
OK, he had a thought about starting up Rapture
and becoming a god.
I think we're aware.
Wait, what's the name of Prince...
Oh, Prince Naveen!
OK, there we go.
I believe I have nailed the X.
Hold on now, hold on now.
Oh, I'm out of ammunition.
I beg your pardon, I'm out of ammunition.
Stop it!
Stop it.
Finally, a bio-shot shooting the St. Clairflint.
Ow!
Thank you, Vega, for your pan generosity.
Get off of that man.
Are these advertisements?
Oh, these are!
I believe these are advertisements for the products
that I may have accessibility to at a later date.
Pick your plasma and evolve.
Now, if I had to pick a plasma,
mine would be telekinesis,
from the other side of the room.
Whoa, who said that?
That was inappropriate conduct.
You can't be saying that kind of stuff.
It's far too...
Now, when I must declare,
when I see a Vita chamber,
it makes me nervous for the fight that's ahead of me.
Possibly even lethal.
The lab aids are starting to call them Big Daddies.
Perhaps they're so cheap.
Well, yes, that's me.
I'm Big Daddy.
Bonded pairs, connected by a lamp that kills.
Why is your southern accent spot on?
I have terrible news for you,
but you are listening to my voice through rose-tinted glasses.
You are my good sport.
You are listening through rose-tinted glasses,
because there's no way in heck this accent
is anything close to what I would earth.
I'm supposed to be enunciating words, my good boy.
But I assure you, I'm just trying my best.
Now, I believe I went the wrong way.
So there's Journey to the Surface.
There's Gift Shop.
Now, that machine back there was asking for Adam,
but I do not have any Adam,
so I need to find a little sister.
But I don't wish to hurt her.
No, no, sorry.
We do not hurt little sisters in this facility.
We respect little sisters from around these parts.
We do, we do.
How much sugar?
All the sugar you can, or some matter we use.
I am a little lost,
but I'm sure the heads-up display will come on shortly
when I seem to appear to have vandalized.
Ooh, no.
Nobody's the white.
Now, that's a shame.
You got to be nice to your fellow men's,
because when you do...
I know the surface, Eleanor.
I spent half a lifetime there,
in service of the common good.
It's spinning the wrong way.
That's not the way the water spins where I'm from.
Well, what's wrong with that old man?
I tell you, you don't have no appreciation for the stomach,
and that's clear as day to me, lady.
Andrew Ryan is correct.
Rapture is deliverance.
Who is flushing their toilet without me?
I'm about to get attacked.
I might be...
I was kind of joking about getting attacked.
Jeez, that was so unrefined of you, little lady.
You're not supposed to sneak up on someone.
Goddamn, where the fuck did you come from?
Where the heck am I supposed to go?
Now, I do apologize.
This is my first playthrough,
so I'm a little bit discombobulated.
First thing in the morning.
Ryan's amusement park.
Okay, Souvenir's is where I am.
Did we get into...
Okay, we're just gonna go down the stairs.
That's my guess of where we're supposed to go.
Have you played Bioshock Infinite?
I have yet to be able to play that game.
I did purchase...
Pardon me, I'm losing my words and my vocabulary.
That wasn't very...
Now, do declare Eleanor you're doing more than enough,
helping Big Daddy get over to you.
But I have to admit, I suck.
Okay, you gotta give me some more time, darling.
You have to give me some more time.
Prefer your combat, up close and personal, with drill power.
Your drills do more attacks.
What is this?
Hold on, sorry, I was pressurizing.
Oh, yow.
I do...
What?
It makes them look just like us.
A little bit of brainwashing.
Nice and early, I see.
Fumble, babe.
Well, if I do declare, it's time to ask an old friend for some help.
Okay, good sport.
Now, where is...
There is a little sister ahead.
To get the atom, you must deal with her Big Daddy first.
He will not attack until you do, but be prepared for a fact.
Okay, I'm gonna go machine gun.
I'm not liking where this is going.
And I have to admit, I'll find myself rather scared in this moment.
Now, I don't mean to be a scaredy kid.
All right.
Um...
Now, I must admit, I don't want to scare the little sister, but...
Oh, dear, oh dear.
Okay, well, time to put my big boy pants on.
Goddamn.
I'm spraying.
I'm sorry, it has to be done.
I need to add a more than you do.
I'm sorry to look away, little child.
This is big, but no, leave Bumblebee alone.
He's my problem to deal with.
That belongs to me.
No, Bumblebee.
No, that's a hack tool.
What the fuck are you thinking?
Okay, I apologize.
I'm sorry.
Ah, okay, I guess you're coming with me.
I'm telling the other girls that I have to mess, daddy.
I didn't even adopt you yet.
Alright, you just come along with me.
We're in business.
Yeah.
There are corpses all over Rapture, and little dimples there can sniff out the atom on them.
Find one.
You have adopted a new little sister.
Well, there's only one in her name, M-E-B-Z, okay?
Press and hold X to ask her to lead you to an atom-filled corpse.
Well, press and hold X.
We're...
Okay, thank you, darling.
I'm gonna...
I will let you lead the way.
I will protect us to where we need to go.
One second, darling.
It's well.
It is it, darling?
I don't...
I'm not really sure.
I'm just following your lead, okay?
You just do your thing.
You...
You sniff it out.
Oh, there you go, darling.
She's got a juicy one, but when she starts draining out the atom, the splashes will come
running.
Are you ready before you set her down on that body?
It was too good to be true, okay?
You go down there, darling.
I will protect you, but just don't be afraid to use that needle.
Set up traps, M-E-B-Z.
Absolutely.
M-E-B-Z.
Your little sister?
Oh.
Oh, I don't like...
Oh, pardon me, I was a little scared there.
I do not like when the music suddenly...
Stop it.
I
Y'all are too greedy y'all too greedy. I'm also out of
the the
the thing
Please stop
You're scaring me more than you're scaring the child
I'm more scared than the child
I
Who is cutting
Stop it. I don't have distance. Who is cutting the door behind stop
I let you know
Are you please get back on my back my goodness that was terrifying don't do that again now
You know the stakes son, but a plasmid costs a bit more Adam yet keep it up
Darling you're gonna have to leave me to another corpse
I mean another angel wink wink because I believe the little sisters see them as angels even though they're not
I'm holding eggs. Sorry. I'm holding it. It's so hard to do the voices
You are out of ease find I
Well
There are the two shops are right there. Why yes, of course, they're right
How are you?
Please
Did they just keep coming I
Don't really want to spend on
What are you honking that machine for I mean in my apologies, I don't know what happened to my accent
I've always been from the transatlantic areas
I don't actually oh
I don't like that now hold on now. I didn't sign up for this. I did not sign up for this
Hold on time to annihilate them
Stop it
She's not helpless
She's having help because of
Now I don't personally smell it but as long as you're taking me there. I don't mind at all. Please stop coming so close to me
As ammo supposed to be so scarce in this game
Or am I just really dumb and I'm supposed to use my money on that because I feel like I'm being very different now
I'm trying this looks like a scavenging area darling. I think there's something to scav
Venge around here. Yeah, okay. This looks very scavenging. Yes
I can't sleep myself. I guess it's just be with me. Mr. Voice recorder
And your sleeping bag
I
Don't really need money for anything in this game, but consumables lie health and ammunition. All right
I see I will definitely be purchasing a lot more
booleates
Because I'm certainly running out. I didn't realize I didn't why do you look so real fuck you
Present air, okay
Okay, I'm just stop it. I
Don't have ammunition for this
So I think I'm gonna have to swap back to my voice again a bit crazy trying to
Figure out what I'm supposed to do
Well, there's an oil slick
slick
Fuck you beach
Right on
I mean, I don't sorry. I don't know. I'm not from Scotland
Scalene
We need my bullet I need my bullets. Oh my god, you're right. I need my bullets, right? Okay. We're just gonna buy
If I don't need to hold on to money like that, I'm just buying some bullets
Doggy in the wind
Hold up in this workshop surrounded by those whale and brats trying to beat their way in they want my food my guns
They want it all
I got a plan
I'm gonna fix up the transport stuff that's been rusted in the main way pumpkin space. Be careful
I do not hate you Delta
Indeed, I care for you in equal measure to any other
Sentient creature, but I cannot sacrifice a thousand of my children
For one rebellious son
Son wait, is that my grandson? Is that my morhen?
Please reload
You
A slicer is healed at health station hack them to turn them into traps
Is that what I was showing me before
I'm not speaking to you. Yeah, I don't think anyone's fucking speaking to me
Sorry, I forgot I can do these trap things
Sorry, I'm getting absolutely shagged right now. I'm I just
Oh, thank god get on my back. Gee. Sorry. This is really difficult for me
All right, chief
We've almost got enough at them now to get the rest you'll have to take care of that little sister
There should be one of the air vents. They favor in the workshop bring her down there
Right
Sophia's brain a bit
I'm trying to scavenge, but I think I just look I thought you were a lie
On the surface the scientist invests the power I like the animatronic look
Praise the sun
Say no
So this little sister is this that was cute. I like the little animatronic
Five nights
But the man says no the man is holding us down
Oh
I like this
POV when people said it can't you can't make a broken literally me but the men
Why are they so mean to me
Uh
I don't want to go in it when he's getting a lich cube. He's got hurt muscle
I'm all bending
so just
Constantly buying you stuff again
Let's see why not
Okay, I'm came to get in there. It's not the best but it'll do
It'll do. I'm sure I'm totally not gonna
Suck that badly. I'm sorry. I'm trying to scavenge
I mean, uh, apologize. I don't know what came over there
Just enough adam for our purposes and the girls are likely try to repay you somehow
But rapture's a high stakes town son and she is a jackpot
You just have to be willing to take it all
You're no more adam than the price of one plasmid. So the rest is graving
No, down here. It's your survival or hers. I refuse
I refuse sir. Do not dare hurt the little sister
Bringing a little sister to a vent allows you to choose whether to rescue or harvest her
If you harvest her you get maximum adam to spend on plasmid, but she will not survive
If you rescue you get less but she'll be cured
We will rescue my darling little sister. There you go. Goodbye, darling
You go enjoy yourself being human or whatever the fuck. I don't know
Ah
Okay, they
Oh, you feel better now. Well, our tin man had a heart all along
Personally, I call that a liability, but you have a liability
Head to the hall of the future and splice up. Oh, she's so cute. She can't get in
What an adorable little sister. Okay, we will save all the little sisters
I don't even know what adam is quite used for yet. So I don't even know if I made the right decision
That was adorable. That was so sweet
Okay, we have helped a little sister become human
You just spawned in right in front of me. Don't think I didn't see your
Your
Unjustifiable weight. Why the fuck is my melee so bad?
To be honest, I thought my melee would be a bit stronger
You was our first aid kit, I just might
I don't I don't even have enough munitions for this kind of combat. Please stop spawning in
I don't seem to have much evil to my name either
I might just have to artificially purchase
Some extra
Evil or manners. We also
Described it as you made the right choice. Adam gets you more spells. Well, of course it does. It's all coming together now
Why yes, of course my parents did what they could when they could
These are hands everywhere
More
Do not go to war to die for the nation. The only thing you should be doing is
It's inking and and having a good time
Upgrade your weapon. Okay. What can I do?
Um
Damage increases to bow drill spin and the melee. I think I might be doing that because all I seem to do is
Hickle them when I hit them with my drill
Uh, unless there's some sort of meta in bow shock too. I am unaware of
Why are you inking? Did I say something about inking? My apologies
um
the create the
Content creator wants to post their creations online, but the parasites say no
Uh, can can jump at people with the drill yet. No. Okay. I think we'll just do drill damage because
Oh, it now has well, it had something on it. I don't know what the nature of that was but I saw it on the side of my screen
He's saying this job won't change history change history
Tomorrow's a mystery
No, I'm not here. I'm not here shut up. I'm not here
Don't tell them my location. That's cheesy doodling
What I do this
What do you
About shut down panels are used to cancel the alarms and shut down security bots that have been summoned by the alarm
Using the bot panel is free alarms can also be cancelled by successfully hacking. Okay. Well, that's good enough for me
Uh, how do I?
No, don't hack just break it
No, okay, there we go. Wait, I can search that what is it? Did you say search on that?
I'm right. My rivets are full. Are you joking? My rivets are full. I can't do any more
This way I'm going. Oh
I got it. I mean, I did obtain the evil that I so desperately needed. I'm just
What is this a new diary entry?
I know this facility is vital for the preservation
I see a cut scene. Oh, god. This one
I spoke to a young man
Asking you
I
Why is it vermin take two miniature?
Wait, what do you mean? I do declare. I'm afraid y'all come fuzzling me young man. What do you mean vermin tied to?
Although we will be doing vermin tied to again. I thoroughly I thoroughly enjoyed myself
Playing that with you
You would drain the people of their life's blood. Oh, I'd drain them. All right. That's my day job. Thank you very much, ma'am
That's my day job. I drain all the people
And big sister is the hand
When thumbnail so vermin tape
It says only this. Oh, my apologies. I guess it's broken. I will fix it after stream
YouTube has unfortunately updated most things so it broke the chat. It broke the redirects
It is also broken thumbnails apparently because uh, not only myself, but my darling
Sheebie also has found herself
um
Experiencing the thumbnail glitch
Uh, okay. We are going to
upgrade our incineration
Incineration when it absolutely positively has to erupt into flames. Don't wait incinerate. All right. I'm going to equip
Light up enemies to a thousand degrees warning fire spread
Fire spreads well, that's good. So now we can either upgrade our health or we can upgrade the eve link
First aid kits also give you eve. It's pretty big not gonna lie
Get more out of your first aid kits with eve link this revolutionary new gene tonic
Causes your body to produce eve whenever you use a first aid kit. I wouldn't mind that as a passive ability
I find that rather good
Popping gum more like popping
Ejaculate sorry, I apologize
What the
Eve her I have hardly even I do declare. I hardly know that lady. I do not know who she is
Oh, look at all the water
Oh me oh my
Many changes will be flowing
Oh, so this is how I obtain more uh, the hacking needle needs moves slightly slower
Extra new you gain a little more health back from snacking on things increase your maximum eve
Does sound rather bodacious at this time
I've taken it. So now we have no adam, but that's okay
I assume if we need to progress and uh, who are you pissing on?
Oh, am I supposed to
All right now to uh, I believe we backtrack all the way back to a location
We will progress with our courage men we will steal ourselves to continue forth
On our journey not at all scared of what is up ahead because what the fuck was that?
Uh, I do not know what we are about to go up against but the music is terrifying me
I do not know what is ahead, but um
Peace off ghost
I
I'm guessing this is an unnatural fate and she runs away again little piss it bitch
See this is why I have a little sister and you don't you suck please die
Holy mosa son not even a big sister can keep you down
Well, no, I hope not come on back and melt the icing we can say goodbye to this two-bit corny ride
Okay
You cook literally well, thank you
Because parents deserve a night off to enjoy new years, but I met my wit and
I told you
All right
Well, uh blow that up just so we can uh scavenge these much needed supplies
He's gone
James was the only man I ever loved
Now it's like he never even came to rapture
He heard me sing at the limbo room
Came up all bashful. He liked hearing songs about what it's really like to live in this town
Eleanor is progressing brilliantly my physical participation in her birth was
Minimized of course it is vital that I am unhindered by nature's crude bias
I will be above all her intellectual progenitor
Loyal not to her but to the people she will ultimately
save
Outstanding sport
We're hoping to be quite a windfall
Now just open the train tunnel from the security booth there and I'll be able to come on
How could I be so silly as to not ascertain the knowledge that I had to open up the booth
How silly
I bloody locked myself inside. What the fuck have I done?
You can hack the shops if you do the price of items are reduced and you sometimes get free items
Wait get back here Sinclair. What the fuck you you backstabbing two time in
I had thought you some golem of Sinclair's
Brought here to go looms. This ain't lord of the rings through her pocket, but no
You are aware of your plight
I wonder would be so cruel to force a mirror on a man with no face. What?
Lamb was waiting for us come out shooting and start the train
How can I start the train? I don't know what I'm to do
Get on the train. I'm coming Sinclair. What the fuck warning you're about to leave this level
Make sure you done everything you want to do. Yeah, I don't care. Give me the fuck out of here
Well, I'm on the train and we're gonna make it. I think we're gonna make it
Yeah, yeah, yeah spank spank someone else
Golem not golem
test your baby
Ascertain that's a big word for mommy. It is I have to admit I had to ascertain that
Half philosophy that we are too dumb to understand
This is rather oh, okay. Well, you're not a big daddy with the
Why is it the first thing I'm asked to do is fight something big I just come to a new level
I'm stuck
Oh
Am I safe and he's the animulator, you know, they're doing the classic and showing you the balls trying to box us in kid
This is a goddamn city wide lockdown
To keep the train moving you need the security override key from the local governor grace halloween
She kicked me out of my own hotel down here. The Sinclair deluxe find her and get that key
The Sinclair deluxe
All right, well if you insist
Hack, okay, right bumper
Door control. Oh, I can just press x. Well, I didn't have to take this out when I do apologize for how dumb I am
Red result of successful have the security door now open. Okay, but let me just take out my gun
Oh
Anti personnel rounds 50 caliber. I don't really know the difference
But the game has given me more ammunitions which makes me
Rather hesitant for what comes next
And it is also giving me
Okay, I believe we have a fight my game or senses are tingling
And not the good kind to tinker, you know the
What are you doing?
I didn't really want to interrupt you weren't attacking me so I just
I assumed he was all right to be honest. That was rather weird. What on earth were you were you praying for?
Give yourself unto her. No, I don't
What do you see ahead? I see
A lot of things what we're already halfway through the game that can't
Is this is that true or is the backtracking in this game?
Are we already halfway through the game when I looked up on them into webs?
It says this game was about 10 hours long whether or not that is true if you were to play on
Uh, normal difficulty or hard difficulty. There's no way we're already through the game that far. I'm afraid I don't quite believe it
She ahead and where's the rest of the body. Oh my was that uh gentleman decapitated. Can I
What is repug?
Now I definitely I don't
Me
Like
No, but I'm friendly I've changed my ways I was dead for 10 years, but I come back
Why are the music so creepy stop it? I hate when the music is creepy
I feel like they're coming behind me behind me behind my derriere. Okay. What the fuck? Okay
I don't know where or what the bots are, but I'm gonna snap them if I see him around the corner
You are not alone
I would give anything to my sport
I guess grace is home
But that big lug just dropped half my damn hotel in your way now to break through that mess
I expect you're gonna have to work out how he got so burly
Burly
Jean bang yourself a genetic research camera son
You can pick up any number of tricks from a splicer with one of those try the pawn shop downtown
The pawn shop. I'm afraid that's already my specialty
Welcome to the gene bank. The gene bank allows you to customize your current loader
Load out of plasmids and tonic. Okay, so I can
All right. Well, I'm already missing a slot and I don't actually have anything extra to place in so I do apologize
Not quite necessary for what
What I'm trying to achieve
Uh, will we try and hack one of these I've actually never attempted before
Oh piss what the
What the fuck was that?
Well, I got a first aid kit. So actually I'm not gonna complain. That was actually rather decent
Gameplay from myself. Yes
I got an aspirin for a headache if I have one
All papa's drops the worst neighborhood in rapture
She gave me a hell of an opportunity to raise up some uh
affordable housing
When Atlantic Express was constructing their luxury passenger line
Why is this place was hollowed out beneath as flypouses for the railway crew
Nobody was supposed to reside down here long term. But when you're broken this town, you're not exactly swimming in alternatives
I don't favor spending more than an hour or so down here at the time
There ain't a side of the tracks more wrong than under them
What
What is
There's a lot of noises going on in this vicinity and uh
I have to admit it's making me rather nervous
Okay friendly big daddy, that's fine. I don't need to do nothing when they're big daddy
The the campaign is not instigating that I need more at them at this point in time
So I do not have any motivations to
A what?
Did he say the p word
Did he say the p word I think he actually said the p word
He did in fact ask you if you were calling him a p word. Yeah, you know, let's
Whoa
What is his thing at me
Well, there's the pawn shop, but it's bolted up tight. You'll have to find another way inside I expect
Oh
Oh, do you guys not have that insult in America?
What do they expect to keep enough drug stash in this clinic to slice up a rhinoceros?
Of course every poor soul in the drops gonna start beating down your door
It's my job to think up a new key code to keep them out. It seems like every other day now
Nuts, I'm all over for a while at the fishbowl tiner
Is there a number on the fishbowl?
All papa's drops the worst neighborhood in rapture, but it's a hell of an opportunity to raise
We use the f word instead refling when Atlantic Express was constructing their luxury passenger line
This place was hollowed out beneath as flowerpouses for the railway crew
Nobody was supposed to reside down here long term, but when you're broke in this town, you're not exactly swimming in alternatives
I don't favor spending more than an hour or so down here at a time
There ain't a side of the tracks more wrong than under them
All right
Now there is a daddy here, but I'm not interested in instigating anything without daddy
I don't need to add them daddy's happy with this daughter. I'm just gonna leave him be
Search containers
Something shining I hear it. What are you shining? Oh, I got a shot. I don't mind if I do
The clinic code is zero zero four seven. Well, you
Well, don't mind if I knew me mustang and sally
Even though mustang and sally is actually uh, two handed pistol. Okay, please stop. Please stop. You're scaring me
I don't have a bumblebee to my
Ow, something's getting me stop it. I can't see this
Who or what is this?
Telekinesis
All right, I'll
Okay, I'll let you two just do your thing over there. I can hear the daddy does the daddy fight
I'm not grabbing no child
Go much closer with the shotgun think of it as a melee weapon when starting to get some order of fresh kind of sounds more
Indian. Oh, I ain't trying to make fun of nothing
I'm literally just doing uh the transatlantic accent, but it's an absolute off. Okay. Uh, the number was zero zero four seven zero zero four
Seven man. I'm just so good. He's got the wrong idea
You're not responsible for turning elinor into a little sister. No, I'm not just slaves and you only recently broke free
I am I supposed to rescue the system put her through here
Uh, I actually starting to think I'm supposed to save that little sister back there and free her
Oh dear. All right. All right. All right, southern bell strong. It sounds good to me. You want a roleplay like this?
Oh, sweet pea. You needing some help to relax
Why don't I play with your hair sugar? You just rest your head on my lap and I look after you real nice
It's okay if you're tired and need to go to sleep
You did have an awfully long day today
Now we're gonna try and find
Uh, the little sister because we're gonna save her from the daddy that was back here if I'm not mistaken
I'm a little turned around but
Uh, I do hear. Oh, yeah, they're a piece of beef
No stop
All right, we are gonna
Okay, they seem to keep respawning here
So we are gonna have to be rather rather speed things up rather fast. Oh, and I'm already out of ammo
I'm
Working on it. I'm working on it
Little sister you're gonna have to get out of here. You're not gonna like what happens next
Uh, all right. All right. All right, stop it
Hold on I'm reloading hold on
Oh dear, okay, there we go. Where are you darling?
I need to get you in this motherfucking tunnel like right now adopt please and then go through that motherfucking tunnel
That is behind you because they are respawning behind us. I have no time. Fuck it search
Wait, oh no, I have to fucking continue to search Jesus our pop is so yeah, good luck
I'm gonna regret this so much, but I'm gonna shove her in the tunnel next in a minute
The monster has taken a number of our babies for his own
Tin daddy is hollow like a jail cell that needs filling and the world will never suffer
You know
You are not good pappermail. I'm afraid I got it all out of my system if you did not hear yesterday's audio
I did not expect to say what I said at the end of the audio. I was rather non-verbal due to the uh
Mentality that I was in during uh that recording session if you would like to call it that
But I did enjoy myself thoroughly
Uh
I'm putting you in the god damn tunnel. I'm afraid I'm out of evil. So I may lay only
That's okay. You're allowed to hit me as long as you're not hitting her
Go check out the audio later. It was for fucking minutes long. I can't last long
I will read it up. Hmm. Oh you finished
All right, and you go darling
Yes, yes, yes. Okay now
What you're gonna do is you're gonna climb in this tunnel and become human again. Okay
So you just
You just go and be safe. All right, darling. You just do your thing on you go. All right
Go find ten and bomb. She'll look after you real nice. Okay on you go. Thank you, John
Okay, hurry up before one another enemy comes in because I ain't I don't act. I'm out of evo
The video that Twitter audio was five
Okay, in you go
We can't go gotta make sure she's safe. We can't go just yet. We have to make sure
All right. See you later. You don't need to
Let's uh continue on
We will rescavenge for these uh trap rivets
Because it seems to
Oh, there's some evil up there. Okay, we don't actually need it right now
Come on
You what you called me a moop. How dare you sir? I do not take kindly to such accusations of being a moop
Yeah
You could have collected more atom
Is there too
To
I assume every little sister can do two bodies
If that is my judgment, this is to be active
Did that see
Oh, I'm out of ammunition's how embarrassed you
Hi, I'm like every time
Choo choo
This is the end of the line
Monk
Oh the turrets main, uh, I definitely need to purchase more
shortly because uh
I'm a hella. Wait, why are you shooting?
Can my own to dale hurt me
I'm uh, oh my goodness. Sorry. I don't know what I was saying. That sounded like a crazy person
What I was trying to communicate was uh, am I able to
Authenticiously, I don't know what the fuck that word means
Uh, I'm just gonna scavenge a little bit. Oh, no, I'm not because there's tons of enemies that way
Uh, I don't really actually want to go that way. I guess the store is locked the store is not well
Okay, I'm just going to follow the arrow because there's too much going on right now. I'm to go down. Okay. We're going down
Oh, something's tingling
And it's money
What?
You go a Reese you got yourselves a research camera press the rat trigger well focused on an enemy to start researching on the target
That thing's a miracle in technicolor kid
Works like a movie color start the film rolling before you open fire on a splice
And then anything you hit it with tells you more about his dna. Let's give it a dry run, shall we?
I dropped everything I was doing to ink as soon as I heard the first 10 seconds of that audio
Oh
Use plasma and weapons during research
What?
Oh
I think I missed that
Camera spits out a prize once in a while as you learn what makes a splice a tick
Now find one of those big old brutes and take them out on film
Before long you'll be able to brush aside that mess at the hotel. What?
You go research Bruce Slyther
I'm getting this team notification nice for an achievement, but it's not like popping up
I wonder because I broke I broke the game so I declare I broke the game
Heavens
Uh a whole five, but don't mind if I do is there a munitions
location
No plenty of spices to study. Okay. I can say that four minutes is enough
That camera's a bit like telling a joke each time you tell it the same way it gets a little more stale
So you got to change it up to keep it fresh
Okay, you guys just do the daddy for me. Thank you
Are you okay?
I mean if he's gonna kill them for me, I don't see why I wouldn't just team up with another daddy, honestly
Oh shit wait, he didn't take that
I
Tried
I tried that was a bit shit. I'm like
But it's not even a little girl
Woman daddy are fighting again, honestly
And why are we cooking in this lab? No, hold on a minute
All right, let's just follow the arrow. I guess there wasn't a wee sister here
Yeah
First day
Right, okay hack the machine and then buy stuff
And then everything's cheap
Okay purchase items I would like
Munition lots of it
Uh
Aspirin a dose of aspirin will restore a moderate level of ease
Okay
That's better
It's a lot of money 500 bucks a lot. Is there not a little sister?
I guess no, I guess I didn't have to kill them all no feel bad
But I suck
I mean, I'm a terrible person inside and out. I can't believe I I did such a thing. Let me listen to this recording
I wish I could publish this stuff. It's newsman pay dirt
There's one of those big goons now start your camera rolling on him and then let
them have it
I like who he gets angry at me
Is this what I'm supposed to do
Oh
Roots splice a research new ability drill dash devastate your foes with this powerful dash attack
I get stronger
Look at you sport a regular junior shot above and it appears you've picked up a new trick from that big
Yeah, now get back to the Sinclair deluxe and just bust through that mess blocking your way just buzz
Oh
Press B while holding rate trigger to drill dash
So I'm not supposed to explore this area. I guess not. Okay. I'm not I'm not hanging around to find out any extra facts
Okay, I'm just going back to where the game telling me to go
For grace the paradise of Andrew Ryan was most unkind
Why yeah, she spoke against him in song and he had her block listed it left her panellists
But in the family she has found hope a reason to draw breath
Ask yourself delta do you deserve to take it from her?
Uh, yes, I believe there is something very important down there
I swear if I'm going to ship my pantaloons because I'm exploring where I shouldn't be
Why are you respawning I've already been in this location. I wish the game wouldn't respawn
enemies at places I have already been
I swear if you telling me there's something down here when there ain't I'm going to be so scared
What am I looking for I don't I'm not sure oh, there's uh firestorm
Ryan industries presents a warm welcome for your enemies with firestorms
Set your foes afire when they strike you. Okay, that actually was pretty worth. Oh my goodness
It's mints. Why the fuck? Why does the video games always pick on fucking cats and games? I have to admit
I'm not annoying. What's the word
Better upset
Now hold on a minute. I want to take a photo of you real quick. Hold on. I just wanted absolutely a blue little rich
Increase damage
lead head splice
vulnerable to
Antipersonal rise. This is a lot of words for Elmo. I have to admit a lot of words right now
Go down where you fight the brood if you would kind of
Okay, I'll go back one more time
Just take a photo before unaliving them. This is the action shot two minutes later
Okay, now there's something patrolling in here
I
Hold on. Let me really real quick. I'm gonna beat the fuck out of this century to it
Oh, am I gonna hack it? Maybe I should no wait what I can do an action shot on the fucking camera
Okay, increased damage security elements are vulnerable to armor pissing rounds and electricity
Okay, that's rather funny. I find that rather
That did give me a little bit of a tee he on the inside. That was that I found that rather interesting
All right, uh, there is something down here
little
reward for
exploring. Oh my what is this
Here father, it's yours
You are evolving fast, but your heart is getting weaker. I can keep you alive, but you must find me
Oh
My lord, you have run out of plasma slots, but you can
Store or replace them at a later gene bank. That's fine
Confuse your foes into attacking one another. Fuck telekinesis. Actually, no way. Take away incinerate
Wahoo hypnotize your foes laugh as they fight each other
I
Evolved today. Oh my
Oh, but they were so romantic with one another
I do admit that was rather mean of me
Oh, yeah, they were just trying to have a romantical moment together
Mindbreak acquired. I'm very happy. So is this kind of like bonus exploring you should not have come
Um, actually, I encourage it. So I'm not really sure
Bomb goes off in that fancy place up town and
God is in the people
All right
I supposed to get rewarded with supplies for exploring outside just to the 360 right there
Who's gonna come here me night and gale and about how they are
They
Oh, nope, my apologies. I got the
Oh, no, I think I'm fine with the gene bank right now weapon upgrade in that room
In the jazz lounge or in here
That must be back there in the jazz
That says gene bank right there was
Just give oh, I see it. I see it. I believe this is it up here. I apologize
My apologies. What are you there? Thank you very much
now
I would like to
Oh, I'm still missing something. I'm too gay. I'm two hours into the game and I'm actually still missing some I am
Uh, I would like to upgrade the damage of my shotgun
I believe because it seems to
Be good now. Are you okay?
I
Would it be all right if I excuse myself to get myself a little cola would that be all right with you?
Why it's telling me to go well
It's telling me to use the piano hold on
Oh
In real life by all means all right, I'm gonna get me a shoulder
Momentarily to beat this heat that I'm experiencing
because it is summer
in
the Americas
And oh boy, it's hot especially in Louisiana. That's why we like our iced tea
Now it might not necessarily be louisianian, but that's all right
We just doing our things
Well, I'm lucky I saw that oil slick
How on earth did that still hurt me even after that no stop you literally walked through fire to get me good sir
I was how are you not dead?
what
You get electrocuted you get burned and I'm still your enemy. Are you being no get back here?
No, I don't care come and get back here. You're dead
Why am I actually getting
Why are you guys all of a sudden a lot harder out of nowhere? Hold on. I'm beating the absolute
Did that do anything at the top?
Okay, I guess we have to go through
On our big sister's probably the next upgrade
Louisiana down south. We call it a coke. Ah, I say coda
I was a waitress back in the day and there was a lot of
Confuzzlement a lot of confusions
created
Because of just rev up that drill your
Uh slam right through that polar. So I had to specify fool
fool
Fat polar
Or else it sometimes just didn't quite work the weight
Now gracey was on the top floor get on up there and persuade her to give you that override key
Do you want an override key? I'll print that out. Can I have an override key please?
Oh
Well, I didn't realize you was just napping. Excuse me, madame. It was not my intention to upset you in that way. What is this?
Got the rapture blues call dr. Lam. You satisfied low on pep worried about money don't know where to turn
Oh, I have a flashlight
Well, I don't like this one bit
I'm gonna turn around and all these are gonna
I
Are you heartless bro
Who are you calling heartless man when you're the one attacking me? I'm just the one that's you know chilling and stuff
Uh, let's try and hack this I guess bonk
Bonk bonk bonk bonk
Bing bing bing
Might as well put the upgrade and take it, you know, you're drill nerd
I knew it. I was I knew you were gonna do something like that. Now. Just give me one moment. I'm gonna go grab me a pop
Okay, um, I don't even need to
All right
Let me see what's going on. No, don't puke. I was literally gone for a second. I didn't mean nothing
I'm an elite hack. So I am
Little sisters in this level one is with their daddy one is free
Who goes there?
Wait, do I have to
How many endings does this game have does it have multiple endings if I don't get all the little sisters?
What's going on
It's so hot in my room, but I just got an ice breeze
Exactly one second. I'm uh, drink me my soda pop or whatever the what we refer to it back in the rapture
Why
I'm a burp right in your mouth. Do I do apologize? But please do open nice and wide for me
There you go. That's fantastic. Keep that up. You swallowed that. All right, darling
There are multiple endings
All right, well, I hope I at least get the nice ending whether or not I actually get it. There's a whole different story
Who goes there identify yourself
Oh
Am I drunk
Wait, you can get drunk on alcohol in this game. I thought I just get into some trouble
I didn't realize you could get drunk drunk. I guess when I'm consuming them atoms to repair any
HP, etc
You can get you can get drunk by buying alcohol too
I
Wait, why are you running away? Why why the fuck is this a horror map? Let me in
I saw that with the foot is there something running away from
Ah
Real-life kill tip you can get steam in if you drink alcohol. You don't have to drink alcohol
Hell's already filled that one looks
I mean, oh my apologies. Sorry my my action. I don't know what's going on one minute
I pretend I'm from Scotland next minute. I'm transatlantic. I don't know what's going on here
Quick little uh buggers aren't they? Yes, I do declare. I'd rather agree to such um
What's going on here? What is this? A box?
Uh, I think I know why there's a bot shutdown option
Alpha foxy wait, so what do I do this?
No
I'm supposed to hack them and then a bumblebee comes out. I'm not sure
All right, let's see. What are you you have run out of slots, but that's okay. Go to who a gene bank
That's fine. Leave your foes out in the cold with a freezing drill
Well, I don't
I love it. Who are you?
I have a chance to freeze that's kind of cool
Yes, yes, yes, Dr. Lam. Hold on a minute. I need to I need to get back. Oh shit. I forgot to hack that oops
paid fill price
Sorry, I know you're trying to tell me some of the lore right now, but I'm too dumb to figure out how to unlock most slots
I assume it comes later
I'm not dying alone. What are you talking about?
All right
Don't take from your own
I don't know I do this it's gonna like
Your drills run out. No, okay, I guess you can only do one thing
Why did you blow up?
Beast
Sorry, I'm having a stroke trying to talk like that all the time. Give me give me give me five minutes to recover
I'll do it again, but I need to like five minutes
It's like messing up a brain trying to like all complete at the same time
Grace's room is just up ahead
Now she's been sending all manner unkindness your way
So I'm not particular as to how you take that key away from her
But she's old and his grudge against you was based on a misunderstanding
Always the misunderstanding look I'm the good guy. You just don't believe me
Oh, I got a whole evil syringe from her
I
Stony sweet food tea flavor versus original flavor. Oh, we're oh, hey mommy. We're mommy go
Get more bang for your research buck on keen observe carry your analysis further than
I'm not bothered about that one unless I'm like being a dumb dumb. I like it so far
I'm I just I feel like I'm very sucky right now, which is a bit rough, but you can't win them all
Eleanor baby, where are you?
I turned my back and someone took you it happened so quick
I'm not even a half mama to your girl. I couldn't protect you
This poster of dr. Lam in my room is staring me down like
What
Hi, it's big daddy. I know what you hear. Oh, she's not even scared of me gone take it
I won't have you touching me
I'm the good guy. She says she kills everyone. I'm putting everyone other a misery
But baby Eleanor disappeared
And then one day I see her walking with you
looking wrong
You knock me down
broke my jaw
So I'm ready baby snatcher come on in and finish the job. I don't want to kill you
Do I actually have to kill her
There's no way I actually have to kill your call friend grace is unarmed for what it's worth
Sinclair, why do you want me to like perish everyone?
I literally have no interest in her. I have no need to kill her
Come on
You're a bigger man than I am chief. We shouldn't do anything twice about pointing fingers before all the facts are in
Now let's be on our way collect all adam you can before going to the next level
Is that a thing I don't know where to find the little is there a map?
Oh piece
There's no way I'm able to backtrack like that
I
Am I gonna am I gonna lock myself out of progress if I don't collect all that adam?
Like I'm not gonna get stuck Emma
I don't know if I can backtrack successfully my brain doesn't really I'm on level five
There's like five floors to this place. There's no way
Hey
There's no way I think I think I saw you just make it harder
Just find the big daddy
You had me under a gun yet you just walk away
No monster life turns the other cheek
No monster does that
A thinking man does that
You have to save every sister to get good end and I think I already lost so if that's the case
Why is the music so sexy?
I don't the fuck out of you two's music
Wait, so then is it gonna register on my mother's floor now?
Sorry, I'm vending machine
Oh, there's so much backtracking
Can I just make the game difficult for myself and then cry to you when it gets difficult?
Uh, Emma, can I just cry to you when it gets difficult and I get frustrated
If I or how about I make a deal you get another audio on
Alt twitter if I end up getting annoyed at myself at this game
How about that? That's how we're gonna do it. I know the doctor lamb is no liar
Okay, thank you man for trying to keep me right in the game, but I'm just say okay. I'm say
What so she makes the game easier for me now a little bit
Does she feel nice?
This
These whirly birds are custom jobs by an old friend. I'm afraid this is all I can
Bumblebees I have to
Hi bumblebee
She gives me but can they are they stay whole game?
Oh game they stay with me
Oh game these stay or or just level just level. Okay. Okay. Okay. Don't get too excited
I love that noise
I'll do I like the shotgun
I I I I I me when I'm getting a lich cube. Wait, what's going on? Oh, right
Flying clap trap level
What are you doing?
I like them locking on
All right, leave them alone they're mine not yours
I'm stuck something's going on
Oh, she's never even saw the damn thing
Oh, you need to get a rest mate
Ah
Okay, there we go
They didn't give the drone so much personality don't worry. I'll give them personality
Hydration shake reef lane
Oh, no, oh
How to have a period you need to see activate
He's about to go kamikaze
He's popping his weak log
Oh
Well, sir, I don't know what to call you now
You've done more than just spare my life
You've opened my eyes
I need to put a few questions to dr. Lamb
You're in trouble dr. Lam's in trouble
Can this cruise just great from looking so far
Do you seek to gain my trust a feeble
No, your crocodile tears may poison her with doubt
But I am not so easy a mark
Oh, no, no, no, no, I'm killing you you have not rescued or harvested all the sisters
You need adam from them to become more powerful. It will be very difficult to okay
Are they near bye at least
So show me the map stop showing me this
Go adam
The one reef link called adam right now just absolutely jerking his pinkers off so
Adam Adam Adam
Jean bank, uh adam a little sister
She's not even on the floor
Ah
I would have to backtrack so much but even the game's telling me I'm making it harder on the fell
Hop on kid and stop the train don't make me pull the whistle now
Yeah, pull the whistle up Mars right where am I going?
Oh, I don't even know where to go
Oh
Right, I can't I can't backtrack I can't be our sorry
You get an audio find up complaining about how hard the game gets okay. You get an audio
It's a win-win for everyone. I can't be ours backtracking
I can't be our specter
Go complete right the train out to poppers drop
Make the cheeks whistle this game doesn't get that hard. Hopefully not. I mean I'm struggling on easy mode
I don't play in legendary right now, but I'm struggling on easy mode
Mission failed successfully. Honestly, right. I'll definitely be up some more
I just don't like being on my own. I wish there was more bumblebee
Hear me or ye who would murder the lamb of god? He shall never reach her god
Yeah
Oh
You mained
It's the audio already picked I'll probably just see what you can't do
Oh
I believe you could jerry rigged to drain the park out that had let you stroll right inside
Get to those pumps and hurry
Oh, I'll pump already. Oh my god. Wait. Well, I just picked up random adam
Hello, I'm like you but stronger
I see father wales has parted you from your craft
And yet you cling to life just random adam around
Today delta you meet a man who has no fear of death and for elena he would burn with a smile
Huh
All right
Show them what we got boys
Does that big daddy have an rpg
Oh per sunny get him
Oh have no shorts have no fuel have a camera
Maybe
Oh my god, the recoil is insane
I
Damage increase big daddy's are vulnerable to armor pierce around. I mean, yeah good. I didn't kill him yet. Oh, well, that doesn't work
Oh wait, he doesn't look like a big daddy. Oh
Stop it. We're like fucking trying to mow each other down
I'm sorry kiddo. It's fine. It's fine. It's fine. Hop on board. You're fine. It's okay. Just jump on board
All right, we're gonna need to collect some adam darlin
Yeah, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. Show me. Show me pumpkin
Gather the family
Mother of mercy, I think that was simon wales. What's he done to himself?
He and his brother were shown in lots of these aren't unsettled. We're just summoned by
He's got a kind of charge down in the pumping station expect a reckoning when you arrive
Her her vanquished captors effigy
This way darlin
Here oh pumpkin this is in the middle of the
That's what you want you get what you want darlin, but oh my god, you can't have picked something a bit less central
Let me just set up the perimeter for
I gotta just hurt myself. I'm on thing
Right, okay
To the angel, please be safe
Yep, yep, yep, yep, be careful though. There might be some nasty people trying to steal the angel from you
So just be careful and hurry up
It is the wee angel just seems to be picked me up. That's all
I am out of evil this probably couldn't have gone any worse
She said watch my line
I just throw a nuke on a child you weirdo. Oh, I don't like this adam collection thing
It makes me rather nervous
Are you done right she's chugging the cola that's the good news
Right climb aboard darlin
Okay, okay
Yep, yep, yep, yep, yep. We're together
We're together. We're together. We're together
Oh my god, that makes me so nervous. Sorry. I'm gonna as I almost kill myself
I'm gonna need to start buying stuff gather garden purchase gene upgrade. What health pool
plasma
Electro ball stun multiple opponents with a language. That looks all right
Move through the world as an invisible plasma. That's a unique one
and
I like to bolt to
Yeah, I'm gonna go to sleep rest well. Thank you for hanging me flim
Electro bolt to maybe health upgrade
What do you the freezes op in this game winter blast?
Anyone winter blast
Uh, are you winning strongy a little bit a little bit I'm
That's
Slightly difficult slightly difficult could be easier
Freeze and shatter. Okay winter blast. Yep
Put it instead of telekinesis
I've literally never had to use this since and then winter blast two is a hundred
came
And then
What are you your gene bank? I need I need ammo machine
And where's your other
Okay, okay, we'll go harvest this and then we'll put her away. So she's safe
I am very low on supplies though for a fight. I'm not sure I want to do this
And
I'm just playing. Oh, here we go. This is what I need. Uh, these are bullet animal bullets
I need to start hacking you stop wasting my money
Okay, hold on. Let me get this corpse for her. So she's happy and then we'll pop her away
Oh
Right, okay, you do that and I will protect you just be quick. Okay. Just be really quick because I have one heel
I have literally nothing else. Okay, darlin. I have one heel
Well, I think I've messed up to be honest. I think I should have bought health pack
Oh
I don't have any long range weapon
To be honest, I'm gonna say something controversial and you guys aren't gonna like it
For easy mode the shit isn't easy
I said what I said the shit is not easy for easy mode
Like actual controversial it's uh, this is not easy. I'm not finding this easy at all
Wait, any time
I'm like, stop it. I'm not finding this easy. I'm finding this hard
Literally me when the me when the game says it's easy, but it's not
I'm finding it difficult. I'm feeling oh my god. I have 69 dollars
Like right I'm gonna put her away. She needs to go through a tunnel
Oh, I bet you find it hard I do
Like that's why I was like, okay, I think
I think that's why we're gonna be right you go home
Are we sure it's not accidentally on normal mode again the pro gamer is struggling
I'm though like I'm not even embarrassed to admit. I'm like fuck. So this is getting hard
What is it not graphed?
This is easy like when a game's easy, I expect to like tank everything
Why why is a big sister coming for me? I've not even done anything
I'm literally about to die. I'm not even kidding. I'm literally about to die in game because I suck so badly
Okay
Um, oh it's nice. We'll last this why did they randomly give me this fight
I
This is literally the best I can do I think
Your drill is out of fuel. It's always out of fucking fuel
Like
Oh
My god, I
Terribly need supplies of any kind terribly
I don't even know how I'm alive right now
Big sister comes when you save a little sister
At least by Michelle corn was easy
Okay, let's just fall over the map tells me go good job mom
Man, we're uh, I need one of you guys to remote into my PC
Hydration
Oh, I said come soon to find me
New plasma security command take control raptor security with a security command enemy security and your own friendly
Bots and turrets will follow the blue ball and attack
the blue ball
Ryan
Is bio shock infinite this hard need more be swarm
Left trigger to command security
You're not security. You're just a guy
Oh
Hi bumblebee have you come to save my gameplay?
Something's right over there
Right what so if I hack these something happen
Get a blue bonus while hacking for longer friendly in
Simlish raid. Oh my god. Thank you for the raid. I'm embarrassed. Uh, I'm so sorry
I'm playing this game for the first time and I absolutely suck. I'm so sorry
Simlish raid
Hi, how did it go? Is it good?
Did it go well I I had to
Tap out
I had to tap out when she was making me but she was like
Oh, wait, what the fuck am I doing? She's like, oh strong. He's ambitious and I was like, oh, she thinks I'm ambitious
I was like getting all the compliments and stuff
Sorry, I thought I was supposed to help me. I'm supposed to go up these stairs. I'm getting an ILA edge
I am I absolutely suck it took me forever to make all the girls
Stop because I was like, oh
I need to
I'm not supposed to do I don't know where the code is
I
Looks like the good father's kept up with the code locks
Time was only way to join with dark lamb was to beg and you should have seen mercy getting the pizza
Oh, did you end up playing some sims as well? I thought you were just doing character create
Search corpses for loot. Um, yeah as she was like, oh strong. He's uh all a
Ambitious and I'm like stuff. I'm gonna cream
Yeah, like 10 minutes of gameplay I was gonna play uh
game boards
In the sims where we're all pure like I was gonna make us in the sims
I'm delayed it because I didn't realize that she be was gonna do some sports. I delayed it a little
You have an amazing accent by the way, I don't know what you're just talking about. I'm actually from I'm uh atlantic
Let me in let me in new goal find Daniel
Damn Daniel back at it again
for any of you are who are familiar with
Um this game. I just want to say apologies. No, you do not have to watch the gameplay
I absolutely suck at this. I'm literally on easy mode and uh, it's like it. Why did you just sound like Eddie Murphy?
No, it's not a transatlantic accent. I've been doing it
um
The transatlantic accent because it's what the games they like
Oh, I do declare and they sound like this and they talk our parts and nas and our familiar
um
And they put a little trill on the end of their voice and the way they say certain terminologies
But I do thank you, uh
that to the harem
and
Oh Jesus what is going on in here?
I appear to have unlocked a spear a harpoon
I'm gonna fuck her with that harpoon
Oh
My I did not it is what the fuck are you? No, I'm not dealing with that. So it's up theory
No one call her tell her it's called a transatlantic accent
It's called transatlantic because people came over from
Maddening notion that I owe you
He just tanked to that. Are you serious? He just tanked that entire thing
Oh, yeah
Beast what are you the drills empty? I've only got spears. Maybe he's weak to spears
I don't know what you're saying because I'm too busy investing in the gameplay
I'm doing busy
The spear gun is percent up drops
My god
Is this easy mode? No, it's not. I'm shite. He's off
Oh, wait, I'm supposed to go this way. Oh, I hate when I have to go that way because that's where the enemies are
Oh, I'm out of ammo
Do you mind? Oh my god, I'm just sorry. I'm just constantly available. Oh my god, Sony. Just go to reload station
I know I know I know I should go and spend all my money's at reload station, but I suck
And this is why you're getting an audio at the end of this for begging for forgiveness for this terrible gameplay
No, I don't want to hack it. I want to destroy it. I'm like literally under it
Geez
So
What is this game about? You know more than I do. I'm gonna be honest. You know more than I do
It's about constantly being out of ammo and desperately searching through your inventory for a fucking splice of a lick of ammo
Because uh, I'm getting desperate
But yeah, I'm glad she'd be at a good uh Sims 4 collab
I was gonna do it that we're poor and we're opening up a restaurant, but there's like this thing called like rags to riches
um
that you can do
Um, and I was just gonna do that
Hey
Sorry, I thought I had to use tail pieces to do that
Um, and it's called rags to riches and I was gonna make this open up a hotel. Hey, no not a hotel cafe
What's going on
Ah, sorry, I'm literally just gonna have to go to drill this again ridiculous
I'm no laughing anymore
Where's that reload station? Yeah, I'm in my nether and these kind of guys. I thought this was gonna be easy
What's that?
I'm gonna download a mod tomorrow that makes me have infinite hp. What are you talking about?
I would never do something like that. With hackers delayed to your body converts the all
Altered current from a hacked machine into a powerful healing agent hack and heal
If any of you are hacking
Uh, I do have a like
I
Just fuck so much I'm gonna have to look out look out what I'm supposed to do
Watching you play this I wouldn't have known this is easy difficulty without you saying
At least Ryan never what oh congrats if your name's Ryan by the way
So
I think I can hear a big daddy
Like am I not a fucking beast right now?
And I'm getting fucking annihilated
I'm actually I'm sorry. I'm actually download a mod when we play this tomorrow to make this seem easy
Because this is not easy
You just suck. Yes. I'm aware. I suck. Okay, and you swallow
Like I have nothing I have nothing I have fucking nothing
But need my money heals me nothing
I'm nothing but a packet of crisps to my name right now and I'm not even supposed to go this way
Actually, I'm in a tin can start acting like I'm in a tin can because everyone goes you need king can
Oh, is that a boss? Oops. I didn't even know I was going against the boss. Sorry
It's an animal bullet
I'm somehow doing great. Why is the arrow changing? I'm about to go down our art arrow. Where are you trying to take me down here?
No, I'm following the arrow like my life depends on it. Oh, no
I don't even have the resources to fight keepers
I
Assume if I die the game's just like
Bro you can't make this up
Now through this junction is the rest of the alley including the very pump
Okay, hack and they're all behind me right now
Okay, okay, please give me a chance
Like I can't even
I can't even like fully fucking reach
Ah
Right, I've got my bumblebees. That's fine
They're behind me aren't they literally
The world's
You're better. I mean the code is oh sure. I wasn't paying attention to anything being said
Mm-hmm. Oh, I literally says right next to it
Oh
Can't see
No, he's dead
They've cut the power on you you're stuck till the backups kick in I'll help you hold them back check the new moe
The what
Know this beast
Daniel's body may go cold, but his soul rests for the child of the lamb you shall roast
Blacken in the pit and it'll be a grieving brother sent you there
I
Don't know where they're okay, and he's going in right there lovely lovely
Oh, and I'm dead
I'm just gonna have to melee and hope that I get the freeze because this is like astronomically
Not in my favor right now
At least cult of the lamb did it right the drill is run out of fuel tap right trigger
Is biotope infinite this hard like seriously
I'm literally praying for a proc of ice
Or a proc when they hit me that they get put on fire basically
I'm just hating in a corner right now
I'm hating I'm hating if you're struggling here and it's easy the infinite's gonna give me some problems
Monka
Can I just get you guys to play it and then I'll commentate over your gameplay?
That seems fair to me
I
Know lamb is our salvation
You shall not rob us of our literally dropping like one bullet
In bad in milk
I mean it has some difficulties the claim of the person on my bad. I don't know. I'm played it. Sure by him. I'm sure thing
Oh my god, we flown look at the way you're you're killing the enemies. You're so good
Yeah, come up here and fight me because I need I need to get free speck on you. I need that runescape
Uh, what was my other attack security electro or ice oh ice hold on
Okay, ice will be got it ice will be ice
Okay, there may be we may have a chance we may have a chance
We may have a chance. Hold on. It's not over
It's not over yet. We may have a chance. Oh, I can't even scavenge his body
I
Thought it's supposed to be like whenever they do easy mode it's supposed to be like
Enemies have way less health. You have way more damage resources, etc
But like I don't even have the ability to kill big daddy's right now
Is the cost of paradise
To end pain to end sin
Like he doesn't even have a wing so he's not even
Never main two is just hard
Oh
Sorry, I deserve take away after this game. Huh?
That's how I'm like go away. I just killed one of you
I don't care
And I've
Freezing a million today
She needs a drill there. Oh, I do have
No, piss it off. I'm not even doing this. I'm not even doing this, but I've go away. I need all the resources and I've got nothing
Other than a fucking pillowcase
I think I've got some sort going on
I need a weapons upgrade
I
Don't know why the audio got delayed there
Okay, so if I blow them up like with ace
I actually mess it up for myself because I can't even look their bodies because there's nothing left over at loot. Yeah, like
I
Feel like I'm making a worse for myself using my
Better shock adults had strange habits of making you clear waves of the wave
They said extend that gameplay the gameplay
Now we aren't doing a full we're doing the rest of the game tomorrow, so
I'm sure I can find a mod to make put myself in god mode
At least increase the fucking
Obviously
Therapy would be
God mode literally I'm putting god mode on out of here
Power to the people
But your voice inspires the people
I am asking you to join a much larger family
Though your body fail, but stroney, you're not taking damage. I'm just like
like
Machine gun damage
Reinforced barrels will live for increased muzzle pressure and a higher damage output. I just feel like going all in on damage
So it doesn't matter what have to use it's damageable. So when I do finally find some
Is there a boss fight in here? I think there may be
Hold on
Okay
Okay, god damn games like pop you halfway across the map. I need to take the drill
Okay, the drill in the ace combo definitely works
Can you have a moment to think geez
Oh, this isn't
Like literally this isn't
Easy mode by the way easy mode by the way
Easy fucking mode by the way
Can't make a shit off i'm fucking mid fight like having to go grab some stuff
Is that the boss?
Is that the fucking boss oh for fuck's sake
Can I hack that for myself
Uh, i'm i can hack mid fight you're joking right you're actually joking
Is that i knew the boss
I'm out of fucking fuel
I bloody hope this is the boss i'm getting shagged from that like over there. I literally have to back a pull off
I don't know. Okay. Uh, does anything happen?
Fuck oh
Oh my god, it may be hard, but I hope you're having fun at least like i'm enjoying the story and everything but like
I don't want to fucking
I have a stroke like
Trying to like sweat about user's management. I'm trying to enjoy the story like this is so cool
I'm trying to like rescue my daughter type thing
Like I will finish it don't get me wrong i'm gonna finish it because I really want to get to the point with the story but
Yeah, no, I know I've not rescued them all because I don't have fucking ammo or anything to rescue them
Oh my god, get to fuck honestly
Just take me to the next one sauce, but yours are all getting an audio
I'm like i'm really gonna be our word myself in this audio. I don't even care like i'm raging
Give me a map
You
To demonstrate
Have I just killed myself lambs overloading the pumps the place is coming down get to Dionysus park
To where
I'm in a bit too heavy in this suit to be doing anything of that accord
I'm currently dying from laughter. Well because i'm raging at this game
No, he's giving up
I'm gonna artwork
I don't want to ruin it but I think you need to save them
I don't have the resources to save them. I genuinely don't and i've already missed some anyway
And i'm like i'm not going back so i'm not but
If I get the pissy pissy shitey shitey ending because i'm a pissy pissy shitey shitey player then that's on me
Sorry, but it's not your fault
I'm going to fucking the place is going are you joking the place is literally going down and i'm your fucking concern
I don't care the place is going down and i am somehow your concern
That doesn't make any sense. Get out. It's me. I'm literally being body blocked
The place is coming down and is that gonna hurt if I stand on it? I don't know probably
Search for loot
Well, I can breathe under water so i'm not really sure what the problem is here because none of them can
Look delta it is the world for which you strive
Alone among the dead
Hey, no, I just want my wane and then to go. Thanks. That's literally what I want
I don't know what you're smoking lamb, but I ain't whatever
Like see can the game just be can I just flood the entire place? So this is the gameplay that would be fantastic not gonna lie
What are you you're a little voice clip
Oh
I was mommy doing good, but i'm gonna R word you or myself
Genocide wrote confirmed
Oh, I'm no fucking wait, why are you raging at me? Is that a we assist? That's a big sister, right? That's fine
Yeah, come fight me outside your little fart your little wet fart come outside and take me
Is there any hidden adam around here?
Yes, our word is is that a problem
Where's me?
I had such a good experience in bio shock one. I don't remember struggling so hard
I just this just feels like resource management and i'm like this is a rooty-tooty shooty game
Please stop making me have to like stop every two seconds to access a machine to scavenge
Like i'm constantly doing this picking up stuff from bodies like bro. Let me root and shoot and shoot and keep going
Oh, no, they're busy. Oh, no, it's wrong. We don't fit it. I'll for you
I'll eat you
Rendezvous I've been in this place before higher on the streets and I said i'm a time to go
Whose footsteps for those they weren't mine. I heard someone's first time
You call that let me in
Just hack the machines and buy full packed
Am I against an invisible enemy now? Don't piss me off anymore than i'm already pissed off. Am I going against an invisible enemy?
That I can only tell from the freaking footsteps
Okay hack and then we'll go for the blue one
Is that free i think it was free now pick it up
Okay, now that i've hacked everything i'm going to buy all the animals actually we'll do full health first
I'm gonna do animals
I literally don't have enough and i've gotten achievement for something. I don't know what it is
I don't know what the code is. Yeah
I'm about to get shagged by something. I can't you see be honest
I hocus pocus there's a pizza on your focus meat piece of ghost
Oh
Don't do that again. Do you understand?
Which i saw in the pc
I'm just playing keyboard
Uh controller because I suck
Oh my god, i'm feeling a pizza. I don't know about you, but i'm feeling a pizza. This is gonna be my reward
I have to step away for a bit. So sorry if i'm repeating up. No, no you're fine
But one of the best ways to make this game easier is to take tons of pictures of different
Is it not just one and done buffs against them?
I
Got like an a plus for that
I have thank you sash power. I thought it was like one photo and then you're done. So
Right, I'll take more photos
What the music's so creepy I don't know
No, there are several levels
He's ready he wants a cup of tea i'm making
Then what because i've not frozen them
I want you to take me
I don't
The fox it why did you take that at least be so full right now
You brought this on yourself
Yes, uh stoney tea time. So if I hack it I get a heal for free, right
This place is very
Oh, is he fighting a big daddy?
Well the good news is i've located a new train car
But the station's still locked down and we're not alone in here. I see a shadow in the security booth
I'll lay low while you have a gander
Oh
I don't see a shadow. I see a smoking gun
Well, hello boys the name stan pool. What's your tribute quality paper?
Before the locals stopped reading and started finding other uses for it
Anyway, i'm going to cut a deal fellas come by the train station. I'm here in the booth
I need to take a photo
Wait, so I just keep going for it
I'm like am I making snuff films right now
I feel like I'm making snuff films right now. I'm not sure I'm supposed to be doing that
Uh
Now you're playing with power. Hello
You're making research
You drained out the park the little sisters are already starting through uh, no goes around
So does it matter how I kill them? Can I just kill them the same method or?
I can't have that
Like
I need to switch it up like
I don't know I don't know. Why are you oh upgrade station?
Um
Let me know we can make money for veal or other ways
See it as a part you're a hundred percent making snuff films literally like hold on a minute. What's going on here?
All right, we know how to kill them even better and I was like this is
Uh
The game awards you for being creative
All right, um
I'm just going for damage on everything because I don't know what I'm going to have ammo on and what I'm not
Going to how much money only up 45 dollars. So that's not happening
We can hack this
That's kind of
We did it we hacked things
Okay
Let's progress hello
Sorry, you don't feel so well, but I hope you're resting
and generally says
You what the enemies are weakest again
Why I don't know how I did that time. Wait, hold on
Okay, snuff film time
I got an e for that
Oh
Yeah, like they're dropping me five bullets per lake gun. I'm picking up like that
Why have you given me? How have you gifted me a launcher? I'm just a big daddy with a launcher
Should you trust me with this
I think I'm going to take it off until we have a fate to use it on
I'm not sure you should trust me with something like this. I have a terrible track record of
Are you trolling?
I mess up one
And the thing hates me
Right, I get to keep on at least
Wait, they send an even more wherever lags
Oh
I messed up wait am I taking health damage when I mess up?
Am I am I gonna mental what's going on?
I'm gonna weave it mental
Did they like leave me alone after I messed up?
That just makes me like never want to hack anything
If the if the result of messing up a hack is like oh a billion enemies come flying at you that literally just discards
Look, okay. Okay. You're gonna have to be nice to me. Oh, hello
Okay, so dead men tell no tales, right? Right wrong. See with anime
Every stiff's got a story and lamb knows how to read it
If that stuff makes it back to her
I'm an obituary. So I want you to take the story of Dionysus park and bury it
Get rid of the little sisters for me your way
Do that and I'll unlock the station here scouts honor
Why are you scared of a little sister? I'd say he's hiding something but he sort of took the fun out of that one
He's locked in the security booth. However, so we'll have to play along find those sisters
Oh, he doesn't want to do something to the sisters does he?
The bumblebee just falls
Check your map
Oh
There's one up ahead to the left and then one straight ahead
Okay, this way and then to the left
Moe bumblebees have already perished
The little sisters are I'm gonna go rest well. Thank you for hanging
Sorry about the non MLG gameplay
Oh, this looks like a battle fucking arena if I've ever seen one you do
Okay, a little to the left. There should be a sister down here. Yes, there is
I think I'm a bit too loud to be making noises. Oh, that's my friend. Oh, we're getting bombed. That's okay. I didn't want to live anyway
Are you squishing me right now?
The tricky part about photos is that you can't take infinite photos of the same men and weper fight due to diminishing returns
You need to take photos on them each fight
Also, I think photos on robots makes them easier to hack
Okay
So does the game just want me to have everything?
I
Shouldn't be cacking so stressful. They wanted me to have a good time should have thought like that
Like even hacked this is expensive
I don't need drill fuel because I don't really use that so much. I ain't paid to have more hacked art
Bleeding me fucking dry, honestly
Oh
No more giving me money for game advice because
I just suck in general anyway. I don't know what way I'm going for it. Well, what are you doing this way?
Stand this way
Keep your money's keep your money's don't don't give me money's for game advice
I know just repeat if someone if someone puts a really good thing and everyone just spam it at the same time
Just copy and paste. Okay, because don't don't give me money's for reading shit a video game
There she is
Little tyke wants to be in pictures
Real cute now get rid of the muscle and deal with her
I
Am right you want to get out of the way for this because you're not gonna you're gonna like what happens next
Okay
All right, sorry pumpkin up you come you're fine. You're gonna get released and all that jazz
Bumblebee it literally bumblebee took all the hit time on me
See you put it at work and all that adam ends up in you
But you're sort of a silent partner. So that's tops with me
I can hear that enemy
Please be safe. Please be safe. Please be safe
I
Oh my god
Yeah
Who is me?
Oh my god, see I can't handle these fights. We are gonna finish it tomorrow
But if you see me like with fucking unlimited ammo, please don't judge me or like unlimited med kits or some shit
this is like
No, fucking easy-peasy, but we'll at least explore this for supplies, but
Evade cameras more easily there's
This spawn and continuously when harvest them as long as you're just having fun
Like I said, I really want to get to the bottom of the pot. I like this
Oh
So when you see me pop up with infinite health tomorrow
I will judge so hard judge will you want sorry, but when a game says easy mode, I expect to not be like fucking resource managing
controversial take
Oh
So fucking controversial easy mode should be easy
Projectile vomit
Oh that redini splicers winning because I don't know which one I didn't even have fun here
I
Me currently recording my
elite gameplay
of
Where that yeah, I'm surprised I never going in for that. Hey, can we
Hack only to hack again the flies
Why am I drunk?
I
I'm fucking steaming apparently how many enemies do you see more than enough?
I hear a daddy
She's so good at hacking
I can hear a daddy, but I've not pissed them off ever. I can't even have them
So what take a left?
Oh wait, if I still got a win on my back. Oh, I do
Sorry, oh my god, I have to do two adam run
I
Of you Beach
Speeder
Oh, I'm sure this isn't going to go bad at all.
Oh my god, stop respawning, seriously.
Alright, have fun.
Hopefully I won't get you killed.
Oh, I'm already dead.
Oh wait, hold on.
Splacer, increase movement speed.
That would be helpful if I had any bullets.
Sorry, there's loads of noises coming in.
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay.
This slow-mo's, I'm getting annihilated.
Oh no, that's even worse.
Did you see that?
Oh, that was awful.
Oh my god, right, Angel's all gone.
Oh, that was horrific.
Oh, I did not like that.
I didn't like it either, darling.
That was freaky.
Little pumpkin pie.
And you won't get away with it.
Oops, let's see what's wrong there.
This is definitely the wrong way.
I'm not to go upstairs at all right now.
That's why they're called spider slayzers.
How is it that it goes so far into the game?
I'm not found that yet.
Right, that's just ammunition.
Damn, you got punished hardcore.
Wait, what was that?
No, I can't, scavenge format.
Reefling's crawling on the roof.
Okay, you go in there, darling.
See you later alligator, you've done great.
Thanks for blinding me on the way out.
No, that's fine, I really enjoyed that.
Father, this atom you found contains memories from all the bodies here.
Normally, only a little sister can see them,
but I can show you what Stanley is trying to hide.
Yeah?
When mother was taken away, Stanley was left in charge of Dionysus Park.
She spent all her money through these mad parties.
It was like he was trying to ruin her.
You okay there?
Keep your eye on the brass ring, brother.
Find the rest of the sisters.
Right, need to make sure she's safe.
Come on, you can do it.
Use that upper body strength.
Let's progress.
By going a little to the right, bing.
Yo!
Oh, that didn't kill him?
My name's Johnny.
Did he just reveal lore?
Let me hack this.
Bonk, bonk, bonk, bonk.
My name's Johnny.
Hmm.
I think we may need to just...
I'm kinda at the mercy of what the game be offering me.
Jimmy Beezer, Johnny Coles, what's next?
JC, what's JC?
JC.
The promenade.
I'm gonna pick this up first.
Oh, let me be selfish.
Increase damage!
Fuck yeah, that's literally all I want.
Right, okay, I'm literally Photoshopping everyone.
I will create an AI video right now of me annihilating these forces.
Is this...?
Why?
This is terrible.
I'm getting a Bravo, I guess because I've already done it before.
What's this, a carousel?
Right, we've already been here.
Wait, so what way to do it? What was this, though?
No, she is done this way. Okay.
She can prompt.
The game overs get pretty nasty, too.
Game overs? Like, if I die? Or did I miss on this one?
Your next bitch.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, you can't...
What in the... What in the purple ink was that?
Actually, I'm probably better with this one.
Oh, have I... Have you...
It's not fell time!
Okay.
Bunk!
I got an A for that.
Well, because I did multiple things.
Oh, I don't have incinerate.
I assume that's where I'm supposed to go.
The knife, well, that's the shortcut.
No, it just seems like a dead end.
Come on, man.
There she is.
I hope that bodyguard ain't one of your long losts.
My long losts? Wait, are these all my buddies?
Primer didn't 15 increase the dill damage.
The dill?
Oh, my game broke.
No, I just glitched out. Sorry.
Bruh, relax!
Fuckin' tube, I was complete that game, you bum.
Is that... Can I do the picture thing again?
Okay, I just need to deny that.
Oh, no, sorry, there's something going on.
Something is...
Motherfucker!
Oh, my God.
Up you come.
Up to popsy, you're fine, you're fine, it's fine, you're fine.
Don't worry about it.
Not dill drill.
Wait, did I say dill?
Dill damage? Sorry.
I'm already thinking about what happens next, you know what I'm saying?
After this, where...
Oh, there's a dead body right behind me that she wants to harvest.
Okay, okay.
Don't give me anything difficult now, if you're a little healed again.
Don't give me anything difficult.
I need something long range for this room.
Sorry, I'm getting...
Stop, you're so creepy!
They hurt alone!
I did like the gameplay of actually being the big daddy, though.
Okay.
Ah, I'm done up.
Ah, right, you...
Yes, you're going home very soon.
I'm not!
If anything, I'm the one that's getting got here.
I literally cannot keep up with these fights.
Get riveted, get riveted, get riveted.
Honestly, I've like put my damage up and everything.
Oh, I'm trying to scavenge everything I can.
That's why you know that noise you hear that goes do do do do do do.
That's literally me trying to scavenge everything in one go.
Right, apparently the other dead body is in this room up here.
If she won't...
I have one health.
I don't think I've got the freaking thing for this.
That ammo.
I need a bit better than that.
There's a healing session up there.
I think I'm going to have to go for it before I do this fight, please.
This is...
She's not looking good for me, mate.
She's not looking good for me.
I think that's pretty yank.
What about you?
Oh, you're just health and nothing more?
Oh, no, I'll hack it and all that.
Don't tingling me.
Get a blue bonus while hacking for a friendly fucking thing or whatever.
I'm working on it, I'm working on it.
Ooh, what are you?
Who needs guns when you've got a drill and nearly unlimited plasmid power?
What? What's that?
That doesn't tell me what it is though.
I won't put it on the new equipment camera.
Right, because that bot is on my side, I think we're just going to have to send it.
Just fucking hack it.
I can't achieve anything for that.
Wait, that doesn't give me...
Oh, I thought it would give me a med kit.
Right, off you pop, darling, good luck.
Either we die here or we don't, because I can't keep up with this.
I literally can't keep up with these fights with the little sisters.
I'm sorry, but it's getting too...
It's actually getting so difficult for me really.
Ah!
The snuff films are shaped!
Okay, hold on, let's do a freeze.
Maybe the snuff films might enjoy that a bit more.
What?
It's too much.
I have no heals.
Are you done?
Okay, get the fuck on board.
Yes, you do have the best adding, so please don't let me die.
It's up to you if I perish, seriously, heal me.
Wait, it still costs me money to heal?
I can't believe she's gotten this far in Legendary Mode.
Thank you, Reefling, I have, I've gotten so far.
I'm just fucking trying to scavenge anything.
But you know what, I'd really like to scavenge, not ammo.
I would actually really like to scavenge.
Right, you go home.
Yep, all done, right, off you pop, and you go...
See you later, alligator, and a wild crocodile.
I don't want to unlock more passive ability floats.
Right, off you pop.
That's me there.
I confronted Stanley.
Said I'd tell mother what he had done.
He panicked, took me away, and sold me to an orphanage.
I tried to fight back.
I remember biting his hand, but...
Father, he's the reason I was turned into a little sister.
Uh-huh.
So what, I'm supposed to be filled with rage?
Right, I need to make sure she gets them safely.
I'm patrolling, don't you worry, darling, I got ya.
Make sure she's okay, right, she's okay.
At least one.
What, is there something in this room?
It sounds like there's a big daddy in here, but...
Now, you were just a deep sea explorer with Iron Cajones, pal.
Cajones.
But Ryan was sure you were a spook, so his people locked you up.
Erased your damn name. Goodbye, Johnny.
Sorry, I know you're in the middle of a really important dialogue.
I am so fucking empty of anything right now.
I couldn't give less of a shit.
So, what on Earth?
Increased damage, a Christmas fucking miracle.
In a single sublime mosaic, Eleanor.
Consider the genius you deny her with every stolen drop.
Does this feel like I'm crouching?
No fucking more.
Right, Jean Bank.
I assume this, yeah, this is one if I want to sort shit out, but I don't know.
I'm Pippa Pig.
Wait, why does that sound like I'm Pippa Pig?
Do that again.
I'm Pippa Pig.
That rocket launcher backfires so badly. It absolutely did.
Got a B for that.
New Jean Bank.
Got an E for that, not there.
Wait, you won't.
A bit of Merlot.
I'm a bit too steaming right now to be able to do this.
I'm just gonna let, okay, are you good?
How much of a tank is this gentleman?
You're okay, you're okay, it's fine, you're probably better in the hands of me than him.
Oh my gosh.
Finding a gathering garden, spend Adam opens up more slots for passive.
What the fuck is a gathering garden?
It says GG.
Oh, it was right out there, sorry, hold on.
There's a GG out here, let me go get it.
Ow, what the fuck?
That was actually really funny, sorry, that was really funny.
Okay, there's apparently a GG to my left.
Congratulations, you have found your first reward from the little ones for saving the little sisters.
A teddy bear.
A proud, get even more out of the time spent with your little sister.
Any little sister working for you will gather slightly more Adam.
Okay, that sounds good.
I don't, I forgot what Evelyn is, so whatever, I'll just...
Oh thanks, darling.
Right, Jean, upgrade.
Increase your maximum Eve, pyramids, look.
Plasmas gives, and unlock an additional pyramid.
Oh my god, there's so many, it keeps going.
You have 600.
And I would walk 600 Adams, and I would suck 600 Adams.
Just to be that big daddy that sucks on all your Adams.
If you're listening carefully, you can hear a brain developing wrinkle.
Uh, is it maximize, increase your maximum Eve, health upgrade, and then plasma swap.
Okay, empty swap.
Okay.
Is it gene tonic, additional gene, oh it's genes that I want.
Yeah.
How do I send them?
It seems to be automatically filling them, which I do appreciate.
Uh, health and Eve, electrical bolt too.
Yeah, that sounds good.
Yeah, electrical bolt too, sounds good.
New and improved.
Charge up.
Okay, charge up.
Charge, bitch.
Release the warmth of swingy insects that seek your enemies.
Defy spirit Eve.
Telekinesis boots on, drinking alcohol restores that.
Wait, alcohol takes away my Eve?
Is that why I have none?
Plasmas use glass Eve.
It just is all physical damage.
I think that's what I need.
Is that the passive?
Oh, it is the passive, put it in that one.
Okay.
Okay, and then give me more gene swap.
And then I'll buy something to put in it.
Drill lurker, quiet your footsteps.
You know, I'm not here trying to be a PC, PC, PC.
You take no damage from electricity, you deal more damage when you use electrical attacks.
I like that, that machine buster, increased damage against cameras, short circuit.
Every time you hack something, you gain a little health and Eve.
Reduce duration, you gain a little extra health.
Hacking success zone, headhunter, your headshot, nope.
You can carry more than a first aid kit, just one.
You take less damage from fire and inflict more damage when you use fire.
Health stations also refill your Eve.
Repair and name friendly bots and turrets.
Well, considering the bumblebees don't stay with me.
You were basically playing a level 20 area as level one.
You mean I'm not making the R word audio?
Reduce bender machine.
You emit a burst of ace when struck by melee attacks, which has a chance to freeze.
Can I do that with the fire one?
Because I have one that's for fire as well.
Increase research bonus, that may be worth it.
I don't know, maybe do health and health, Eve, gene slot, and then we'll buy one more gene.
Great trap, no I'm not blowing up.
I only pass stuff, plasmids use less Eve, shut that in the slot.
I have 45 left, so I don't have enough for anything other than what, careful hacker?
Extra nutrition to be precise.
Get the medical expert.
Medical expert, what are you costing?
Can carry one more, right okay, so I need to buy the slot.
Gene, and then, oh I've only got 10 left.
Oh, did it change its price?
Alright, I just can't do math very quickly, I think I just can't do math.
We'll get that next.
Every three little sisters help you get a wee teddy bear.
Okay, that's cute.
Alright, she wants to take me, oh no there's a corpse back here, hold on.
What are you learning?
Okay, there's a corpse back here, I now have, like, is there not a corpse on it?
Sometimes she's a lie, shouldn't be comfortable to me.
Of course there's a lot of salt for it.
There you go.
Hey, off you pop darling.
It is, you keep that angel company darling.
You keep that angel company darling.
Oh, sorry darling.
I just think I'm gonna have to do that.
How could you?
I'll not be toyed with.
I just got a bomb nade to her.
Y'all done?
Right, climb aboard.
Daddy, are you taking me home too?
Very shortly, yes.
You need to just give me a second,
because we're currently getting annihilated right now,
but it's not your fault, it's my fault because I got killed.
Oh, come on.
There we go.
Also, Strani, you can destroy heal stations to get a free health kit.
I did not know that.
Thank you.
Not bravo for that one.
So I can destroy these?
No, okay, just the heal station.
We're picking up some stuff.
If only she could improve her aim real and true.
There's literally no aim assistance going on,
which I'm very surprised about.
Normally, like when the game acknowledges...
Who goes there?
Sorry, that was a big one.
Sorry.
Normally, the game acknowledges
when you've swapped to a mouse.
Keep on the move to a controller.
I'm out of ammo.
Normally, the game acknowledges
when you've swapped to a mouse,
but your controller will give you all-away.
We are done.
Okay, you're done.
Melee!
See you.
Yeah, yeah.
Yep.
Yes, yes, yes, yes.
Now hurry up.
I need to put you away somewhere safe.
I don't know where to put you.
What does the map tell me?
If I put you back here, hold on.
I need to get rid of her.
Maybe use mine.
Right there.
Yes, yes, yes.
Go be safe, safe, safe, safe, safe.
Bioshock 2 never had amuses even on console games.
God, they just not care.
You okay?
So we should kill him?
Oh no, I'm dogging you in, souls, but you've been such a headache.
I'm dogging you in.
I accept full responsibility for any anger.
You may experience before you die.
Dark Lambs turning up the heat, chief.
Head on back to the train station.
Let's hit the trail.
Through Adam,
Eleanor will become the daughter of the people.
A true utopian.
Brilliant beyond measure,
but utterly selfless.
Yep, yep, yep, yep, yep, yep, yep.
Sorry, I need to bow.
I don't...
Just have them put a rough time
in the kitchen.
That's so light.
Quad, Quad, Quadinoff.
and cruise maxi big sisters are vulnerable to armor pierce them
wouldn't that be cool if i had like i don't know something to help with that
fuckin piss me man is that armor pierce send up armor pierce them
um
i just i don't
easy mode by the way and she's like tanking just everything
why is she getting held like seriously why is she actually getting held
i'm literally modding my game tomorrow to have infinite fucking armor and it just never loses
like the armor because this is getting pretty loose we're getting that audio this is a win
not you celebrating me getting annoyed at the game
sorry i'm getting pizza i think i've decided i'm gonna get like so so in australia they do this
pizza that's called um easier to predict who's denies movements that's something can you see
well i can see their little butterfly trail now um
i'm gonna get it's like chicken pineapple and barbecue sauce it's actually really nice
she'd be giving you a pizza in the sun she'll actually predict if my anger
uh
i spent more time swapping between the fucking weapon
sometimes the advertising price is a suggestion like it's actually really funny sorry that's
years of stanley's betrayal
merely a suggestion in compromising ellen and now he seals his fate you see it was stanley
who turned you into ryan and a 14 dollar ring is responsible for what you have become the
security booth is open now you may have your revenge
am i'll wait am i to keep him alive or am i to kill his arse
sweet jesus lamb no and she just let me hang myself out the oh god don't kill him
come on i'd rather let lamb deal with them i'd rather lamb just let me live i want to let him
live so lamb can like just actually fucking annihilate him you know what i mean
i'm a merciful god
so lamb broke out and she's coming back wow okay didn't say that coming but okay
that is gonna be uh what am i gonna do and i heard some of these a lot of these people down here
talking some of them i know
mother's not lying this time father he really did it to both of us
sparing people is a trigger for bear or ending
so lamb broke out and she's coming back
okay didn't say that coming but okay that is gonna be
oh no
elevator music oh anonymous thank you for the 20 tip you didn't put a message
is that to encourage me to keep going so i don't end up r-wording myself in an audio
angrily r-word self in an audio actually that's such a bizarre fucking sentence structure
end of the line if we have to finish the game
we must use an atom to force all rapture's minds and memories into the poor girl lamb reckons it'll
make that child mommy did you catch that vealers on holidays now are we what does that mean
ladies beneath fontaine headquarters and to keep you alive we need to sneak in what does that mean
if we're on holodex is that a good thing is that promotion do we need to tweet about it is it like
that needs to tell management to tweet about it because it's a big achievement
there's still a bit left of the game from what i remember you're part of an uh i like the sentence
right well i took away from that ryan is responsible for what i've become addicted to strong
holodex is the youtuber wiki should we should i tell management to tweet about it and make
a tweet about it is it fake should i make a tell management to make a tweet like thank you for all
your support of the vealers girls that uh they've made it on holodex after just shy of three months
yeah okay hold on hold on let me just uh send management uh message real quick uh
something something why am i in a group called penis
who added me to a group called pina she be added me to a group called penis what the
fuck are you she be uh she be his uh
okay hold on
how dare asia send me a message
yeah okay that's a message for after stream
can't do that right now um celebration tweets holodex something something later
that's in my notes i will do that my collab is good for the team
so
atlantic uh i mean honestly we're looking a little bit close to the end if this map is
anything to go by now i did say 10 hours which is why i put part two like for later
so should i wrap it up now so part two is still me i don't i'm not i'm not sure what to do
from a gaming perspective you're like non-indie devils
big enough to be registered on the vtuber pokedex this is the best way to describe it
yeah that's cute honestly you rush the game a lot i don't know
you have a fair bit to go i mean there's plenty to go okay we'll go to the next map and then
i'll wrap up there so there's still some meat to the game tomorrow
this facility belongs to the city now to ryan industry didn't always be the least until the
rioting subsides while it is unfortunate that such measures had to be taken i must admit
it is gratifying to see this building condemned
about it i mean my pinterest yeah i have to update everyone's patreon's and stuff i've got a lot
of background stuff to do today um management of contact in the clippers for the program
am i not allowed to kill you though
how strange i don't know why i'm allowed to kill
when you see meat it reminds me of the thai stream did you like it i think it went really well
i i listened to some of it because i was like oh surely they could still hear me a little bit
when i'm talking nope when i was thigh cupping the microphone you could hear nothing all you heard was
with ear cupping basically is how it went uh i thought it wasn't that bad it's definitely not
bad the thai stream was amazing we did try and tell you i'm a little bit of a dumb dumb please
daddy don't clip that what the fuck um as a voice post uh are you a master of research no i'm a
master of baiting uh get the most out of your unlock damage bonuses
honestly storing the gene bank for now um yeah i don't i don't normally say daddy like
just straight up like please hurry daddy like that please hurry daddy wrap my legs around you
please hurry daddy okay yeah okay i got it i still got it baby still got it
my name is gilbert alexander and by the time you hear this i will be clinically insane
oh i am recording these diaries in advance as a last ditch effort to assist anyone i might
threaten in dealing with me my next message awaits you beyond the security checkpoint
i can't spend it there's no gg station the bioscan will ensure that you're sane enough to meet it
turn it boy robes a bank sounds pieces fuck oh peek is fun as i recall he was involved in big
daddy development from the beginning big daddy had something to do with you and eleanor son
the vanguard bus is coming everybody jump on it from ellie to france and cisco to
Paris and mayorka sackle
right if there's adam hiding in the sea then i'm going to him
homey's called adam dork in their pintas right now i see it i see it how did i get around
search create all there's like why does it just look like a fishy though
wait oh no i'm supposed to go this way
i was wrapped you're looking i mean it looks all right i suppose that's why you need a train
to get from building to building because they can't have a building too big or the pressure's too much
the atoms come from a sea slug oh my god sea slug for gen two come pray
that's it forcing forcing a girl to like me because we're the same
what was that i didn't see what it was it was just purple that's all i feel
sort of purple
i don't want to set the world
go
Oh my god!
A little squeeze about your knees. What was that?
Where are you?
Alright.
Been a while since I've used any of that.
Hmm? Wasn't there not a guy up here?
Monk!
Oh, she's coming to get me.
There's profit. Wait, have I maxed out on them and that's why I can't capture them anymore?
I think so! I think, can you max out on someone?
Oh, hell, that has to be Gil, Alex.
You don't fit in with the poor, poor thing?
Hi. Sorry, that song's really stuck in my head right now.
The song wasn't even like that, it was just like my brain was like...
Bye.
Okay.
Grease damage.
Okay. Take whatever he had on him, jeez.
Okay, we're in.
That was anti-climactic. That was the easiest part of the game.
Penetrate. Oh!
Uh, they're giving me some supplies as well.
Please be patient, gentle.
Did it work?
What? What? What? What? What? What? What? What? What? What? What?
There's the station for respawning. Are we about to get jumped?
Hmm?
What?
Okay.
Okay, great. If you're so keen to help, the restrooms need a good scrap.
It's a clerk to help you along.
I think I hear a big daddy.
Are you up here?
Okay, let's see. What have we got? One procs on my mind.
Well...
What the fuck is that?
Oh, jeez, Louise!
Please stop you're killing me, but like, successfully.
You're fine, you're fine, breathe, breathe, breathe, you're fine, you're fine.
Promise you're okay. Harder, literally, it's harder than that fucking miniboss fight that was there two times ago.
I'm not sure whoever, like, balanced easy mode, but man did not pay attention to the game, like, sorry.
What am I to do?
I'm sorry, I need to get your stuff right. What would you like?
Oh, this? Okay, right, here you go.
Right, you enjoy grabbing all that, knock yourself out.
There you go, honey bun. All yours.
Right, you just quickly do that because I actually don't have a lot to my name right now.
There you go.
Well, that sounds absolute horrifying. What even are you?
What? Are you a mini-daddy?
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Nope, nope, nope, nope.
I'm not speaking stress or just a wee bit hold on hold on a reload
daddy's trying his best but he's failing dramatically please just die
are you're still alive you've got to be kidding me where is they
okay you're done you're done you're done
I'm gonna be honest kid this is getting really hard to keep you alive this is
getting really fucking hard to keep you alive
literally it's like pick up ammo one billet it doesn't help me
inside my body what thing I look in the mirror and I see a free I remember very
little just an artificial sense of peace and compulsive hunger for Adam Alexander
is trying to help me adjust he's responsible for part of my condition but
he wants to make a man's
whoa please give give me see slug already out mule congratulations you've won a
battle of wits with a home appliance with a home appliance don't be so rude
in a scavenger for this oh can I reach it no I can't reach it must be from the
other side
dude oh here we go oh god another one right okay darling make it quick that's
all I'm saying make it quick wrap it up make it quick wrap it up wrap it up
wrap it up
I think I might need to do fire because fire does like why am I the monster why
aren't you
these don't need to put you need pictures damn it I'm in cringe I miss increase
that much that's all I want and I didn't really kill a live
oh my god
yeah on my back you're going in that motherfucking shit oh my god I can't he
keep up so I'm actually cheating then next time we build this game I'm serious
like I'm please don't be surprised when I'm cheesy doodling I'm sick of like
scavenging every freaking every fight it's getting it's getting pernickety and
not the good kind like this is just annoying straight up annoying right you
go home the dinis are tough don't forget the deal yes I probably shouldn't spend
your Adam yes I was gonna pop her away and then your work oh wait sorry I need
to watch it sorry I'm on patrol no one's going for you now you're fine keep
grown but that's the fun part what desperate for ammo and pleading with the
game to give me some I don't know I don't know chief I don't know the drills
the strongest weapon in the game with that actually
had a my next station that can put that vending machine genetic things back
there on the wall I don't know how many extra slots I have I got my scary jean
bank special tonics one two three and four it looks like there's four that
I could have on right now but I don't
electrical form maybe incinerate I'll do another health and an ease change the
passive to get drill buffs and just use the drill decoy security command telecom
uses those hands after delay extra nutrition no headhunter
cameras and turrets take longer to see take less damage from fire I don't even
get attacked by fire health stations refill is all handy man I mean if I
need kingdoms that ever increase bizarre my favorite part is the tonic
bills I went through drill extended real research life is it longer short
circuit to your electrical attacks disable security devices permanent
I mean that's good to me just upgrade that I'm probably doing this terribly
wrong and apologize
shit if you need to do a backup game do you think you'll play wait if I blast
through this I don't know I don't know sorry I didn't mean to work that violent
anger so is that everything that kids select on right okay no
no what are you doing stop it you're trolling me I'm getting trolled around
about the select option stop it get some help damage research are your master
research this day the expert drill specialist they've never claimed to
increase the cost of plasma that limits with inflation to the drill
only fuck no they like passive freeze drill and then what passive sometimes
advertised prices with suggestion wait so I have four things I can still put on
sorry mommy's very special needs right now and can't seem to figure out what this
game wants from me and then just sure but by a shock to made a better job than
one to promote the use of all weapons wait did I not oh what did I not just buy
more slots I must have put just one thing I feel like a dumdum right now and for
fuck's sake never put that stupid drill thing on sorry I need to go it must have
put it on back right and then put sometimes you need a little extra
your pocket through stock up on each hit I'm just happy to be here okay when I
crouching the one to punch is okay I have upgraded some of the weapons I went
all out in damage TV wait for it press button
a lot of it
really don't you dare touch that signal relay delta it's value is 10 times your
I'm not to do something
fire fire fire
can I vacuum what that was correct
Oh, my God, couldn't just insufficient funds for a buyout, Lamal.
Not easy.
Oh, I'm out of everything.
Am I missing some valuable details?
Well, they seem to have a decent amount of ammo in them.
Have to go to sleep.
Right, well, sleepyhead.
Thank you for hanging.
Uh, where do I go?
Where do I go?
Have I been this way?
No, I must have.
I mean, I came upstairs.
So I need to go around this way.
Okay.
Where did you even spawn in?
You must have spawned in behind me.
It wasn't made by Levine, but the team that did try to carry forward the theory somewhat
dependent on the oddly infinite incorporate some of two's variety of combat.
I'm nervous.
If you guys are wanting me to play infinite, I'm nervous.
Wait, so that's not supposed to go here.
Show hint.
Sure.
Show me hint.
Destroy the signal really attached to the front of the box shutdown machine located
in the plasma spectacular theory.
You need to head back stage to get to the theater.
Where?
This way?
That's a laboratory.
What?
This is the theater over here.
Are you a theater?
The plasma showroom.
Please wait to be seen.
We will wait right here.
I don't know, chief.
Looks like we're about to go into a fight.
I don't know about you, Bumblebee, but incinerate this demonstration.
What is it?
Recommending that I swap to incinerate right now?
Probably.
Fucking bloody looks like I've done that.
Bumblebee, can you fuck them up for me?
I'm like halfway across the map over here.
Electric prop demonstration.
Are you okay?
I don't think Bumblebee is feeling so good right now.
Swap jeans.
Put fire on instead of teleka shitness.
I don't have every bother to use it.
Please put incinerate on.
Are you okay?
Ta-da!
He's confused.
They got the set.
If you like the planter, it's an investment atomic that allows you to name and repair them.
When the game be giving you bombs out of nowhere, it's not looking good for me.
Adam Delta.
One little jab in the arm and even a hopeless underperformer can be the ploy of the month.
But you should know.
Look around.
Is it?
Sorry, I know you're in dialogue right now, but it's given...
I'm about to go into a big fight, so I'd rather...
Oh, I have no money, lover.
The rapture consumer is indebted to you.
We are the king of the kink out of our domestic plasma line on you right here.
Well, let's see if you're staying calm.
Step on up and take the spotlight.
Welcome back, Delta.
Ladies and gentlemen,
Contained Futuristic Invite you to shed your skepticism,
Evolve your expectations,
And dissolve your doubt,
As we unveil the...
Bumblebee, you're burning the fuck up.
Can you go behind me?
You're ruining the show.
May I have a volunteer from the audience?
What?
A new enemy type?
Come down, don't be shy.
Think for us.
I fall in love again.
How about you, sir?
How do you even have the guts to say?
Inferno.
That seems like it.
Eh?
All of you!
Where are you?
Oh, please.
You're not the only one that has fire.
I don't want to...
I've set a myth.
Bumblebee Parished.
Oh, God, what are you?
Okay, you're like a mini big daddy.
Okay.
Win?
Oh, dear, oh dear.
That was rather easy.
I did like this weapon.
My boy.
Yeah, boy.
Okay, we did it.
I'm going to get electrocuted, though.
Boom!
Two of four signals destroyed.
Okay, we can do it.
Can I reach you now?
Oh, wait, telekinesis.
I just got rid of it.
I just took off telekinesis.
Hold on, let me...
Ah, they respawned.
Hold on.
I just took off telekinesis
and that's clearly what that's for.
Hold on!
Let me grab it.
No?
Help me.
Five, two, five, four.
Four.
Curious.
Animo Bule!
Well...
Oh no, why is this map thing
not showing me where to go?
I didn't pick up any more items.
Is it this way?
Is it still not this way?
No, okay.
Sorry, I'm going too far ahead.
It's because I discovered this way
and I'm like, oh, that's where I'm going to progress, right?
What does the map tell me to do?
Show hen.
Destroy the signal relays attached to the...
located in the marketing department.
Officers are off to the left of the marketing.
Upstairs?
Yes, we recently only have one brand.
Bring some of this share between us all.
The offices are to the right, okay?
I can do that.
Hi.
I wish I had a sniper rifle, honestly.
That doesn't work, you lazy...
Sorry, I apologize for not commenting too much.
It's because I'm, like, playing
and it's hard to, like, commentate
and play something new for the first time
and suck at it even...
like, suck at it terribly.
What the fuck, it's RGB?
Unstable teleport plasmid.
What?
But she can't remove this.
This thing inside my body.
I look in the mirror
and I see a freak.
I remember very little.
Just an artificial sense of peace
and a compulsive hunger for Adam.
Dr. Alexander is trying to help me adjust.
He's responsible for part of my condition.
I keep getting steamed by accident.
Momay's a lot thin.
I'm following the disco light.
Please stop drinking.
Over here now.
Fire.
Okay, so I'm not...
I'm not going to the water for, like, a while.
It's our dirty little secret.
Dirty little secret.
And to be frank, a rapture doesn't really want to know.
Provided the end product is sound.
The volunteers were...
as scarce, even as the economy buckled.
A man named Sinclair approached us
with a seemingly limitless supply.
He rented them to us, found sedated.
No questions asked.
Where's the last one?
I tried to really...
locate in Frank Fontaine's office.
His office is on the second floor.
So I'm on the same level as that.
I'm a bit too big to be jumping a bit like this,
but right in his office.
Surprise, editor!
Fucking gear, eh?
Spent up traps on it?
Okay, the arrow is back, so I guess the game saw
how much I was struggling with my navigation.
I don't know why the arrow doesn't stay with me all the time.
I don't know why it's getting me to touch this.
I'm on E for that one.
Surprise that...
Oh, you already took care of them.
Literally.
Sometimes it's easy mode.
Other times it's like, fucking difficult, difficult, lemon difficult.
Like, what the fuck?
Increase damage against these guys only, or what?
Wait, hold on, hold on.
Got a head off to bed.
Yeah, I don't think anyone else is on today.
I think it was just me, Shivi.
Stop drinking!
Can't help it, sorry.
Yeah, I'm fucking drunk again.
Sorry, I literally can't help it.
Shivi is doing a member stream if you're a hero member, though.
Stop getting steam in, is there anything here I need?
There's a med kit.
Benefits.
We made him pop his clogs.
He couldn't handle it.
What, does she think she's not a baddie?
Ask yourself.
What does Sinclair stand to...?
Hello again.
Hi.
I must assume by now that you're willing to help end my life.
In exchange, I have prepared a friendly security escort for you.
Oh.
Now, there's a switch in here
which will allow you access to the real laboratories where...
where what's left of me awaits you.
What did you do to yourself?
What did you do to yourself, sir?
I'm getting nervous for what I'm about to find.
Stop running like a fool!
Oh!
Stop!
I think I'm going to need to get inferno too.
Because of the damage over time that inferno also offers is like pretty sweet.
I thought I was supposed to have a bot with me.
Well, something's attacking me and I ain't my bot.
What can one of these guys...
Knock it off!
Are they still coming?
Where?
Wrap it up!
Infinite is like Bioshock.
Infinite is like Bioshock 2 gets hectic a lot of times.
Someone said Bioshock 2 is the hardest if you want to put them into categories.
I'm trying to listen to the tape, but it won't let me.
I'm holding A, but it won't let me listen to the tape.
And the tape's gone.
By self-interest.
Now I am nothing more to her than a failed experiment.
My scores on tests of intelligence and moral reasoning are still noteworthy.
I'm trying to tell my uncle and sir wrap up because he keeps coming.
She hasn't planned for me.
Turned in the minutes with speed.
Infinite is fine, but Bioshock 2 gets the hang of it.
What's with mommy?
Me absolutely cringing when I was listening over to that audio that I posted.
Why am I going so...
Why not let me interact with you?
Giving Vince a price.
I know what you're thinking of.
Okay, we're going to find the hidden lab.
I'm looking for a sea slug.
Any slugs that want me to eat them?
Or however else I harvest them?
No, no extra sea slugs.
No.
Okay then.
It was a good audio.
I got lots of marshmallows that were really nice a bit, and I'm happy.
Here's the sea slug.
What?
We'll drink here then.
Am I getting close to the end?
Should I pause or do we just...
Because I'm needing to deal with all the girls' patreons because I'm fucking really behind on them.
But it's because I'm passing hat.
Why is it so dark?
What, I don't like this.
Oh, I don't like this one bit. Why is it giving me all these supplies?
Yeah, there's still quite a bit left.
I can't see anything.
You know how you can't see anything?
I can't see anything either.
Here's our town.
Huh?
Uh-huh.
Mm-hmm.
Okay, kind of seen a little bit there.
I hear electricity, so surely that's...
Nice.
Fucking scared her at night.
Can that be a tag?
I don't know how to add them.
I'm so fucking scared right now.
Oh my god, it's giving me bombs and everything.
Oh my god, it's giving me so many bombs.
Oh god, I'm scared.
Oh god.
Activate the main tower, yeah.
Okay.
I think I'm alone.
Uh-huh.
Eh?
Hey.
Is it up?
What is he?
Uh-huh.
Sunflower.
You want to be top man?
You want to sit in the big chair?
Well, come and take it.
Now, why would you recruit them?
Why would you recruit them?
Don't be selfish.
Don't do that.
Elemental storm.
Why stick with a born routine when discharging?
Pest people use this tonic for a scorching, shocking, chilling surprise.
I don't know what you want from me.
Am I soloing?
Target research has been complete.
A Philly Gundam?
Why the fuck are you giving me that much money?
Yakuza, thank you.
Meow?
What?
You give me money for playing so shilly?
What the fuck?
Thank you.
$68?
What the fuck?
Is this what you like?
Yeah, you like this terrible gameplay?
Yeah.
Yeah, it's really turning you on, isn't it?
It's really getting you in the middle.
I can be your kitten.
Give me a little discord kitten.
Daddy, I want discord mate.
Okay.
Get back there.
Kitten or pup?
I'd never be a kitten.
Or else how am I going to see my classic line?
Obvious!
I don't know what to do.
Okay, that was lucky.
That somehow caught on in time.
New audio, I'll do anything for nature.
Fucking hell.
Oh, $21.
As soon as this is where I'm supposed to go.
Why is there a life chamber
and then a boat shut down
and then a health station?
Hmm.
Try and get the Leo in the room
before I enter the room.
Okay.
I've got my second flower.
Alright, Kale since you.
No?
Am I being pranked?
What?
You mother,
but I thought I got away with it.
I thought I got away with it.
I knew there was a fight in here.
I freaking knew it.
I freaking told it.
It's ruining me.
Oh my god.
I'm getting kidnapped.
Thank you guys.
Okay, they're fully leveled up.
I'm frozen?
Ah.
Uh huh.
I'm okay, Kalee.
Okay, we're okay.
We're okay, we're okay, we're okay.
She's back.
I hope not.
I'm moved.
I actually can't be all still in that face.
You rescued me, sir.
I should have done, I don't know.
I can't even, I'm just happy to like move and I'm doing it.
I can't even freeze.
I can freeze damage.
Apparently.
Don't stand in the flames, nah.
That would be very dangerous and very silly.
Right, you climb aboard.
Yep, you're fine.
Okay, we did it.
Alright, where's your hiding hole?
That, the hiding hole is apparently.
I really can't be arsed with a face,
so I'm just shoving her in the hole right in you.
Yep.
Little sister is smart.
I don't have a little sister voice though.
I sound like a man, I'm a man.
No, they actually bothered to animate her.
Oh, there's two of them now.
New meme ASMR, you beg us to complete the game for you
because it's too difficult.
Real and true, literally, please, I am on my hands and knees.
If your little helpers keep getting interrupted,
we'll gather and tell them to get a move on.
What, so they could do it faster now?
You mean that was a pair call along
and I could have got her to harvest the thing
super fast and easy peasy?
I'm gonna fart in someone's mouth.
You're gonna like it.
See, see.
Yeah.
For him at last, it will be instinct.
Ow.
Hold on.
That fucking snapshot of me like getting obliterated by it.
You find double ammo on destroyed machines,
but that's lovely.
That snapshot of the fucking block
will get coming right for me.
I can hear someone getting in my way.
Okay, we're getting somewhere.
We're getting like stronger in terms of like...
I think...
Natural camouflage.
Need some peace and quiet space in nature.
Stop moving and just fade away.
Remember, not seeing is believing.
Well...
It's time.
I think that one's up the table.
Oh, no.
I'm already out.
I'm getting fucking obliterated.
I can't even see.
I'm getting shagged.
Please stop throwing those fucking things around.
Hey, stop greeting.
You're okay.
Upsie pupsie, you're fine.
Now, natural camouflage with wrench, with opium,
by a short one.
I don't even think I came across that.
Take or choose.
Can I not carry anything?
Why can I not take the dollar he does?
My wallet is full?
Why?
No.
Didn't he make a mechanic where money's every hand
and then be like,
oh, your wallet is bursting at the seams.
No, it's not.
Don't be telling Faberino's like that.
Sorry, I can hear something tingling in.
All right, there you go.
This is where they bound us together, Father.
Playing God.
You were the only good thing that Rapture ever gave me.
Experimented on what, girl?
What's that foxy?
She was to be an heir to my life's work.
She's my problem now.
And this is where they changed her,
bonding her to you.
It's blah, blah, blah.
I forget it.
I'm just going to buy everything.
Since I'm full of money, I'm buying everything.
The child she was died in this room.
Like her being a Barbie.
Hello?
Hi.
I know you're in there.
I know who you are.
Hi.
Oh, wait.
I've already maxed out on those guys.
What?
Did I not?
I was going to say that.
I don't think I'm going to dunk that animal.
I have a Vita chain burst.
Let's me know some buzz what happened.
Something's bursting at the seams.
There's no more wallet.
No, I've not been picked with this game.
Some streams, I'm like super teasy-teasy,
but like because this game, I fucking suck at it.
I'm like trying so hard not to be ridiculous.
This is so bad at all.
All right, sport.
Time to feed the fish.
Head on back to Alexander's tank and put those plants in.
I have a target research complete.
Oh, I've already done on him.
Poor Gilbert.
Wait, that's not have a ween on my back.
I still have a ween on my back.
Oh my God.
I'm like putting her on all these things.
I'm so sorry.
There you go, darling.
I didn't realize I had a ween on my back.
I don't feature the idea of my memories and personality
being stored in the head of some saintly child
like just one more dusty old book library.
There's a lot of recoil on that one, bro.
Whoa.
Did you see that?
They're like fucking immediately to the left.
Wait, did I feel it?
Did those guys get it?
I have, right?
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay.
Sorry, I'm probably going to have to win this one.
Hey, get on my back.
Get on my back.
Where is this funny?
Jesus.
It's not achieving for something.
I'll know after.
I mean, it could have been worse.
This could have been better than I thought.
Is it actually that way?
Okay, it's like literally right out there.
Just because it's so close, yes,
I will allow you to extract the atom.
Go.
Make it quick, darling.
And then I will put you in the safety chamber, okay?
Just make it easy on me because
mommy's getting tired of all these fights, darling.
Wrap it up.
They're like giving me a lot more of those guys.
Where are they?
I hear lots of noises, but I didn't see them.
Who is sending RPGs on a little girl?
What the fuck was that?
Who was that?
Where was the RGB?
Oh.
I knew you, Fanny.
I got him, I got him, I got him, I got him.
You're fine, you're safe.
Yeah.
Are you done?
Okay, there you feel better after that?
Right, come on.
You're going in the chute.
Yes, it's sleepy time for you.
It's way past your bedtime, darling.
Where is your Haiti hole?
Your Haiti hole is right up ahead.
Okay.
I'm going to scavenge a hell of a thing.
Oh, that's good.
Oh, sexy.
So fed.
Right, you go home.
And you pop.
It's from mommy of the year.
You know, I'll piss off a big sister.
Oh.
He's seeking rockets.
Estonia is struggling with the labors of motherhood.
What are you doing?
Is he going to help me in the fight?
Oh, oh.
That's my game book.
I was like, okay, here comes the fight.
Okay, let me try again.
Let me try again.
Whistling.
Sorry, this game is about it.
It is what it is.
Big sister spawning and literally killed my game, honestly.
I don't know if the big daddy was supposed to come in there though,
because there's no way with them.
So.
Hi.
I'll try that again.
Yes, continue.
If I didn't lose too much progress.
Hopefully it saved putting her in the tunnel,
so I don't have to deal with that again.
Let's find out what the last checkpoint is.
You're trolling, right?
You're trolling.
Um.
Ray.
With this in mind,
with this in mind,
I am going to play part two tomorrow and we'll finish it.
I am going to play where we got up to offline, okay?
Is that okay?
Can we do that?
Because I don't know why it didn't, like,
auto save any of that.
That happened in Halo as well.
I don't understand why.
But if that's okay with you guys,
manually say it literally, what the fuck?
Like, forgot that I did everything?
I'm so surprised.
Old games need manual save.
That's rough.
I think I was about to finish that map as well.
That is so, so...
Punishing rip.
Okay, what I'll do is...
I don't think Azura is coming on this show.
No.
Um...
Oh, I can't even redirect anyway.
Because I don't, I'm not even signed in on YouTube
because YouTube, like, they kick me out for some reason.
We're definitely getting that audio ready recently, brah.
Fucking reason.
Oh, I'm gonna have to play that offline on my own,
which makes it even 10 times worse.
You're at the end of the level.
Yep, I figured as much.
I figured we're right at the end of the level.
To be honest, I'd like to watch you play that part.
Well, you want me to just play catch up tomorrow?
I mean, I'm fine.
Refining it, do it with the cheat codes, get that mud mummet.
If you want, we can play it together tomorrow from this part.
I mean, if you don't mind, then I don't mind.
I just didn't want to bore you with, like, playing through a section.
We've already, like, done, you know?
Um...
But if it's no biggie, then that's fine.
Because I was needing to do a shorter stream anyway today
because I need to deal with everyone's Patreon.
And then I think I'm getting a manager put in place, like,
either today or tomorrow, depending on what happens.
And then the Clippers are all gonna be contacted
and all the girls are gonna have new shores
and send a real short, but they're gone and all that jazz.
We can do it tomorrow as long as you're happy.
Okay, as long as you're happy, I'm happy.
I didn't want to be boring and, like, play through the thing.
Unfortunately, I can't redirect into anyone at all,
so, uh, it's just gonna be this.
Um...
We're kinda here for you, not to get me who's never been more quiet.
Should I quickly check out some more small ones?
Um...
Literally never been more quiet.
Just, ugh, infinite, um...
Please read this to yourself.
I'm reading to myself.
Hee-hee-hee.
Um...
Right, okay.
Mommy, forgive me, but you sound so hot when you're mad.
Do I actually...?
I just feel like I sound scared.
Quiet, Lord, you're so strong and we love you.
Love you too, Lucy.
Leaving us in the sea?
This was a great question.
I had a great laugh!
You were laughing at me being fricking terrible at this game!
Are you kidding me?
I'm getting bull...
Why are you bullying me?
Liquid wants to know.
Um...
Eh, what?
My pup is suffering from skill issues?
Or maybe if you say the right thing I could help?
What?
You're gonna mainframe into my PC and play it for me?
Skipping all the power-ups and add-on upgrades while also complaining about game difficulty?
God, I love my...
re...
affectionate cuttlefish!
I volunteer myself for the post-R word stream?
Okay, I'm glad it's not annoying for you.
That's the difference, okay?
I was...
I'm sorry, I find it funny when people rage.
Are you kidding me?
Um...
When you called the little sister pumpkin a male, it's a little sense of cute.
Cuddles on and just listen to the audio during the streamings.
I'm really cute there too.
I'm cute little puppy.
No, yeah, I'm getting that kind of thing for me.
I've got it out of my system, although I'm ovulating tomorrow, so...
You never know.
I volunteer as tribute.
Mommy, I'm back!
Mommy's about to pop off.
Mommy...
The game unfortunately crashed and I lost progress,
but someone said that I was about to finish the game anyway,
like in license 2 or if I didn't slow down my pace.
So it works out in the end.
Mommy, be careful with the mods and code changing
because it can corrupt your save file.
Oh god, right?
Maybe we should just persevere.
I'll persevere.
I've done a bit better with my ammo management and stuff.
I will impregnate this cuttlefish real and true.
Um...
I've inked so hard to your audio in your 20k pic already.
I woke up with a sore bag!
You inked so much you have a sore bag?
Is that even possible?
Is that real or am I being trolled?
Eh...
Hi cuttle, sorry.
Nothing really important to ask.
I only want to hug you.
Hug you, love you.
I love you, Siwi.
The killer.
The killer!
Love you too, Wilson.
Just sit in Riflin's lap and let him carry you through the game.
Literally, I'm about to make an audio about me sitting in your lap
begging for you to carry me through Bioshock
and then I end up just rambling about how much I actually genuinely enjoy the game.
I like the plot, I like everything I'm experiencing.
I just suck at resource management
and I just want to go pew pew and the enemy's dead
and I don't have to think about it.
But I'm actually having to heal and stuff, which is outrageous.
Eh...
Got them muscle spasms for inking?
Yeah, it happens.
I looked like this!
This little inkling.
I love that moat so much.
I need to extend the ink...
the...
Hi, hi, Stroni.
I love you but you're a little underpowered
because you're skipping upgrades.
That's why you're finding it so hard.
I'm not finding it hard.
I'm finding the...
I've got Ne-Amo to my name.
Like...
It's like...
Into one fight and then I've got nothing.
Then I have to scavenge.
And then next fight...
Nothing.
and like that's what i'm struggling with. Dan, do I need to break my record? If you ain't gonna
it's like clear. You struggle with games with cute rages as well. Would that make us your big daddy?
All I want to be my big daddy? Want me to sit on your lap and get all cozy? And you put your arms
around me and the controls in front of that. I'll just focus on sitting on your lap. Nice and comfy.
You can effectively lightning drill smash through the whole game. Fallout 4. I played Fallout 4. It's
Fallout 4 the one that had the railroad track because I got stuck at the railroad track. I couldn't
find the layer to the railroad. I don't know where it was but I did the swan at the pond
in Fallout and then it was like find the railroad track and I couldn't find it and I was stuck.
Cuddle. Well gaming the dream. Yeah that's 4. Yeah I got stuck at that part. If you want me to
play Fallout you're gonna have to hold my hand through the railroad section. I don't know where
it is. I don't know where it is. And I looked up Gates and they're all like oh it's super obvious
just do this and I was like what? What do you mean just do this? I can't see anything. I freaking went
through the car park. I was blowing up to smithereens and all that. They did release that Fallout
London mod. Yeah you just get shanked as soon as you come out of the cryopod. Handholding is good but
before oh no. Handholding. I'll hold your hand through New Vegas. Oh my god it's Fallout 4 multiplayer
that would be even better. You guys literally just show me where to go. You're like here's the quest
go. I'm like yes I will go that way. Lap puppy cuddles trying to distract the refilling the
carry through Bioshock 2 audio. New Vegas has a multiplayer. Can I play New Vegas multiplayer
with you guys? Because I got stuck on it on it but if I play it with you guys then I can't get
stuck so you guys will tell me what to do. Or is it like IP would show? If IP shows rip,
Skyrim has multiplayer too. New Vegas freezes a lot. Probably not unless there's like a mod.
It's really buggy. New Vegas multiplayer is a modern game which is a complicated one. Okay well I can't
even do many things for myself so it'll help you play Fallout Vegas even if I haven't played it.
I got stuck because I accidentally went down a route that I didn't want and then it was asking
me to do like 8 billion side quests and I'm like what's the plot? Let me do the main quest.
Pretty sure IP always shows those mods rip. Well we tried. Single player only. Fallout 76
has natural multiplayer. Can I play the film with you? They have console commands in Fallout.
Hackerman I'm in. Hi there just stopping for my periodic reminder that you are amazingly talented.
Are you joking? Can't even resource manage on a shooter game. I wish so many more people on the
internet were as kind and loving as you my darling. I may not live a genuinely happy life but
you are a constant source of joy. Thank you for all you do. I love you. Love you too love you Flynn.
Thank you for the wonderful all audio for those of us who are the poor very life. Still are you Flynn.
Always good for you goodies. You don't need an exchange of goodies with me. Good arcs then by the
way. What are you talking about? I actually am transatlantic. What are you talking about? Oh this
game is just so intimidating. I dare declare that the ammunition I just simply could not find them
for they were scattered around this rapture among the evil men who did not repent their sins
and turned into my biggest enemies. I'm tired of saying I'm going to go eat rest well.
Rest well, sleep well, sleep the heads. I'm going to chill out and then I'm going to update everyone's
patreon. That's my goal today and then snippets might have an upload tomorrow depending on how
much fuel in the tank I have. I will find out afterwards. Preacher strongy main breaks the
reflins. Hey man. The arcs then isn't funny. I managed to try and maintain it for a little while
but I do have to state that it was rather it was rather making me struggle with the words that
were next to come out of my mouth because normally when I am having rapport with yourself there
reflin it kind of just comes out just as the ink comes out of your tentacle. However,
I tried my best. I did it for a solid hour did I?
And the accent was good. Okay maybe I'll try and maintain it all the way through tomorrow's stream
just to mess with you and don't read this on stream.
Oh no. Just hi mommy. Just wanted to ask if I can get a hug and a kiss.
All the kisses for the weekend. The ink that comes out of your tentacle. I'm trying not to laugh.
What do you mean you're trying not to laugh? I'm having the ceremony. I am explaining to you
how it works from around these parts. At least they put it in the first time. What?
Best five dollars I ever spent for the southern accent. It's rather hard to maintain it
as someone who has only just recently entered the United States of America with this transatlantic
accent. I should try and get that tenet. Wait does my no my reverb is not going to work.
Would you kindly do the multicolored color fish flash thing? I do have the ability to do that
without even trying. Maybe I should oh my arm just came off. Okay don't look at that. My arm just
popped off. Now this is how I look. Unfortunately the chat does not quite work. You do know we now
need a meme southern asmr. I can make you some sweet tea. I can make you some delicious homemade
fried chicken. Speaking of fried chicken I think that's what I'm I know I was gonna get pizza wasn't
that how it was. Moment know your arm. Literally my arm like pops off. Best hand I'm I'm eating
that right now. Oh did I convince did I influence you? I'm an influencer. Oh sorry my sorry I don't
know what happened to my accent there. I'm an influencer and I influenced you to engorge yourself
on pizza and then yeah nice big damn and then let me rub the belly. I forgot that I was talking about
I was thinking about. Now I am gonna be doing a hypnosis stream asmr hypnosis soon again.
I'm not sure if I'm gonna do ear to ear this time. I might just talk in the middle of the
microphone but then do tingles at either side of the ear. I haven't quite decided yet. Maybe I'll
tease you a little about going ear to ear but I it's it's it's the work in progress. It's not
something that can be done overnight you know. Look my twin. I just can't fathom how she's been so
equal as Scottish and Southern at the same time. Well there's this movie called Princess in the Frog
all right and then this character her name is Charlotte in the movie okay and her voice is a
bit lighter than what I'm putting on right now but she has a voice of the south and I am trying to
mimic that to the best of my ability but I kind of sound like Cartman. I sound like Cartman when
I go best on my ability. You better recite my authority. Oh I can see them. Oh Prince Naveen.
I'm sweating like a sinner in church. Oh my I'm so sorry for the sacrilege. I can't help myself
riefling. I must throw myself upon you at this very moment upon this altar. We can do unspeakable
things together. I waited for so long so so long. Nina the voice is here.
I tried I tried but just um at Lamont no. Enkling plus Strone's love equals Prego.
Very soon we are discussing Donut on rewards later in this week.
At the end of every week each one of us becomes a freak tonight the DJ makes a noise.
Um right I am going to go take a little rest and then I'm going to catch up on all the Patreon
shiz that I need. They've got quite a lot to deal with in the background.
Strone could you try a quick Strone cutlet impression?
Oh I don't know. I'm Strone cuttles. I'm Scottish that's all I've got going for me.
Enk right now.
Let me the best impersonator confirm real Andrew.
Right I'm a love all on you um and I am going to play Bioshock tomorrow with you. We will
replay that section but you have a responsibility riefling not just for making me pregnant with
my gen one okay you have another responsibility and you're going to have to tell me to save every
10 minutes or so that you think you can handle that kind of responsibility. Now if you fail
this responsibility your prostate is mine okay that's what you forfeit if you don't remind me.
Is the audio happening? I'm not. I think tomorrow an audio will happen not today I've got too much
responsibilities. This sounds crazy but you know how I posted an audio yesterday um
I kind of because I fell asleep after inking I
I inked and then I didn't take care of any of my responsibilities because of it so I
need to take care of my responsibilities because if I ink again I'm not going to want to do a
single thing because I always get like tired after inking to you so quite can make her angry again.
If you're a zeroes mother and she's a mother humanity are you an endeavor endeavoring to
dominate humanity for the bad? Are you the original problem? No the reeflings changed my heart I don't
want to kill humanity anymore. Just the high table. She's just like me for real for real.
I think tomorrow I'm going to ovulate so I think an audio of that ovulate would be
very nice don't you?
She wants to play bio you want to play bio show you want to get aggravated no I'm going to go get
some work diddly done cut my tentacle mommy go get that good sleep okay thank you so much I give you kisses
and I see you tomorrow I won't redirect you anywhere because like I'm not sending to my
camps and I don't have access to it so I can't actually redirect anywhere but thank you as always
for the support it's been lovely and I do have a really good thing with you uh I hope my shitty
gameplay wasn't too bad though if you guys if you guys find it funny when I start getting
R wordy because I'm raging at a game then okay I'll I'll let myself be more angry in the future how about
that right I see you cutie baturis tomorrow and behave and hydrate and stretch either way is fine
there are two ways to stretch but I don't mean
tongue keep up I love you see you tomorrow bye bye
bye darling I'll see you tomorrow I don't want to hit in the broadcast because it means that's not
work okay okay okay I get pizza pizza time
pork night bed okay right okay bye love you sorry bye I'm stolen I'm sorry I love you bye
enjoy rest okay bye